la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion et le vote sur la
motion de censure déposée en application
de l'article 49 aléa 2 de la
Constitution par Madame Mathilde Panau
monsieur Boris Vallot madame cielle
châelin et Monsieur André chassegne et
146 membres de
l'Assemblée la parole est à Monsieur
Manuel Bompard pour une durée de 10
minutes
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues
ministre il faut que la voix des hommes
sans voix empêche les puissants de
dormir disait l'abé pierre il y a 70 ans
c'est cette voix que j'entends faire
raisonner ici
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tout le monde sait que vous n'êtes qu'un
obligé le président de la République a
fixé votre cap il vous impose ses
ministres il courtcircuitite vos
annonces il s'impose même en conférence
de presse à quelques minutes de votre
discours de politique
générale alors allez dire à celui qui
vous envoie que son règne n'a que trop
duré et qu'en vous censurant notre
intention est bien de le censurer lui de
vous censurer vous tous cette caste
privilégiée à combattre comme l'a dit
dans un rare moment de lucidité votre
Ministre de l'école
privée monsieur le Premier ministre vous
avez eu la semaine dernière 1h 200 pour
présenter votre discours de politique
générale je n'ai aujourd'hui que 10
minutes ce sera insuffisant pour dresser
la liste de toutes vos infamies j'iraai
donc
essentiel il faut vous censurer pour
protéger le peuple des souffrances que
vous voulez lui
infliger augmentation de la facture de
l'électricité et du gaz hausse du prix
de l'alimentation des autoroutes et des
mutuelles doublement de la franchise
médicale réduction des allocations
chômage remise en cause du SMIC refus
d'indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
vous êtes monsieur le Premier ministre
le doux visage de la brutalité
soci il faut vous censurer pour faire
régner l'intérêt général plutôt que
l'entre soi cet entre soi dans votre
gouvernement est la parfaite
illustration celui du séparatisme
scolaire de l'École alsacienne au
collège Stanislas que vous gorgez
d'argent public celui de l'école à deux
vitesses que vous voulez imposer à
marche forcée celui de parcours sup que
vous infligez aux HES
mais pas vos propres enfants celui des
get de riches celui de l'impunité
garantie pour les communes qui refusent
de construire du logement social à qui
vous offrez sur un plateau le
démantellement de la loi
SRU il faut vous censurer pour éétablir
l'égalité face à la loi car tout le pays
a compris désormais que nous voici
revenus au temps du roi soleil que nous
racontait la fontaine que vous soyez
dirigeant de la FNSEA ou syndicaliste
ouvrier PDG de la grande distribution ou
agriculteur de la Confédération paysane
que vous ayez un tracteur ou un gilet
jaune que vous veniez de de Neï ou des
quartiers populaires les jugements de
Monsieur Darmanin vous rendront blanc ou
noir en agissant ainsi c'est l'autorité
de l'État que vous affaiblissez c'est la
force de la loi que vous
détruisez il faut vous censurer pour
protéger la France de votre addiction au
libre échange notre agriculture meurt de
la concurrence
déloyale les pires produits du reste de
monde du monde envahissent nos marchés
mais vous continuez de sacrifier notre
souveraineté alimentaire hier vous
ratifiez un accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande la semaine dernière au
Parlement européen vos députés européens
a voté en faveur de nouveaux accords de
libre échange avec le Chili et le
Kenya aujourd'hui vous faites mine de
rejeter l'accord avec le
Mercosur mais les négociations se
poursuivent en coulisse comme l'a
confirmé la semaine dernière la
Commission européenne mais pour qui nous
prenez-vous incapable de rompre avec
cette idéologie mortifère vous sacrifiez
notre santé et la biodiversité les
agriculteurs ne vivent pas de leur
travail ce sera double ration de
pesticides au revoir les abeilles et
bonjour les cancers et tant pis pour
votre fameux réarmement démographique
quel concept
insupportable il faut vous censurer pour
retirer le pouvoir des mains de
l'oligarchie qui vous commande ces
multinationales dont vous refusez
d'encadrer les marges abandonnant les
producteurs comme les consommateurs ces
grands actionnaires du CAC 40 qui ont
reçu encore cette année un record
historique de dividendes près de 100
milliards c'est super profiteur que vous
protégez cilement alors que le peuple a
froid a faim et dort dans la
[Musique]
rue il faut vous censurer pour protéger
la République de votre mariage hideux
avec l'extrême droite car vous êtes prêt
à tout pour diviser le peuple comme le
vote de la loi immigration l'a montré
même à reprendre les pires propositions
racistes et xénophobes et à jeter en
pature la figure de l'immigré ou du
musulman et quand la cruelle réalité
vous éclate au visage vous transformer
le Conseil constitutionnel en camion
poubelle de vos délires
réactionnaires vous rendez-vous compte
du mal que vous faites à la
[Applaudissements]
France il faut vous censurer pour
établir la voix de la France dans le
monde une France non alignée
indépendante une France qui nous rend
Fiè sur la scène
internationale une France qui dit cesser
le feu quand les tribunaux
internationaux pointent un risque de
génocide à Gaza une France qui fait
quelque chose quand elle occupe comme
c'était le cas le mois dernier la
présidence du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies une France qui n'a pas de
double standard qui ne hiérarchise pas
entre les victimes qui soutient les
décisions de la Cour internationale de
Justice de la même manière quand elle
concerne les peuples
PAL Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
semaine dernière vous avez appelé à
revenir à des principes clairs je vous
cite tu casses tu répares tu salies tu
nettoies tu défies l'autorité on
Tapprend à la
respecter je vous prends donc Monsieur
le Premier Ministre au
mot tu casses l'état tu t'en vas tu
salis la République tu pars avec ta
clique tu défiles Parlement le Parlement
t'apprend à le
respecter mardi dernier vous nous avez
rappelé monsieur le Premier ministre que
vous êtes né en
1989 pour le bicentenaire de la
Révolution
française pour conclure je ferai donc
mien les mots de Saint
juste peuple si le roi est jamais absou
souv toi que nous ne serons plus dignes
de ta confiance et tu pourras nous
accuser de
perfidie alors chers collègues soyons
dignes de la confiance du peuple
censurons le
gouvernement je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés la semaine dernière un nouveau
record a été battu un record qui rend
visiblement fier ses auteurs mais un
record qui je crois ne rend pas tout à
fait honneur à notre débat publ et
démocratique ce record c'est un record
de vitesse de dépôt d'une motion de
censure pour ma prédécesseur à qui je
veux rendre hommage et qui a surmonté 31
motions de censure en 20 mois vous aviez
attendu l'issue de sa déclaration de
politique générale cette fois-ci même
pas je n'avais même pas encore livré mes
orientations ici dans cet hémicycle à
l'occasion de ma déclaration de
politique générale que déjà vous aviez
déposé votre texte comme si les annonces
ne vous intéressaient pas comme si les
actes vous importaient encore moins
comme si tout ce qui comptait c'était le
petit coup politique la recherche de
l'instabilité ou encore la promesse de
l'obstruction il y a des choses qui ne
change pas en revanche vous continuez à
nous donner des leçons de démocratie
interne alors même que vous obéissez
comme avec une télécommande à votre chef
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dès qu'il tweet vous
suivez ses orientations et ses commandes
en nous élisant en 2022 les Français ont
pourtant envoyé un message très clair
alors plutôt que de vous réclamer du
peuple écoutez-le écoutez les Français
ils vous diront qu'ils attendent des
diagnostics clairs et des actes forts
ils vous diront qu'ils en ont assez des
postures permanentes et des oppositions
de principe ils vous confirmeront que
s'ils ont élu une Assemblée nationale
avec une majorité claire mais pas de
majorité absolue c'est parce qu'ils
attendent de chacun de nous dialogue
écoute et construction et que leur
répondez-vous une motion de censure
préventive comme un pied de nez à toute
volonté de dialogue votre déclaration de
politique générale elle est là c'est le
blocage permanent nos compatriotes
demandent des actes pour que le travail
paye mieux et toujours plus que
l'inactivité notre réponse déverrouillée
désmicardisée débureaucratisé votre
réponse le blocage nos compatriotes
demandent des services publics qui
fonctionnent mieux notre réponse plus de
médecins plus de moyens pour l'école
votre réponse le blocage nos
compatriotes demande le respect de
l'autorité partout sur le territoire
notre réponse responsabiliser les
parents renforcer la lutte contre la
drogue une justice plus efficace votre
réponse le blocage nos compatriotes
exige une action résolue contre le
dérèglement climatique notre réponse la
planification écologique continuer
l'accélération de la baisse de nos
émissions trouver des solutions pour
chacun votre réponse le blocage le
blocage le blocage le blocage toujours
et tout le temps c'est votre seul cap et
c'est votre seule promesse envers les
Français mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la France insoumise vous osez
nous accuser de conservatisme venant de
vous cela ne manque pas d'audace à
chacune de vos attaques personnelles à
chacun de vos procès d'intention vous
nous replongez dans le 19e siècle à
chacun de vos appels au matraquage
fiscal à la création de nouvelles
contraintes de nouvelles règles de
nouvelles taxes vous nous replongez dans
le myth iste où toute initiative est
bridée étouffée à chacune de vos
attaques contre l'Europe vous nous
replongez 75 ans en arrière quand notre
continent naviguait dans l'incertitude
au fond votre monde c'est un monde où il
n'y a pas besoin d'Union européenne
c'est un monde où il faut tout taxer
tout le temps et tout
collectiviser c'est un monde où
l'économie n'a pas le droit de parler de
climat le temps passe le monde change
mais vos propositions et vos postures
restent il n'y a pas plus conservateur
que vous le paysage
politique avec mon gouvernement nous
n'avons pas renoncé à la conquête de
nouvelles libertés et de nouveaux droits
moi je suis fier de vouloir adapter le
travail aux nouvelles attentes des
salariés moi je suis fier de continuer à
lutter contre les rentes et de faire de
l'émancipation un des Caps de notre
action je suis fier de mener une
transition écologique ambitieuse qui
prépare une société où l'on vit mieux et
pas une société de la régression qui
pénaliserait d'abord les classes
moyennes et les plus fragiles fier avec
le compteépant universel de vouloir
permettre à chacun d'organiser sa vie
comme il l'entend de travailler plus
quand ils le souhaitent et moins quand
ils font d'une famille ou doit s'occuper
d'un proche je suis fier de me battre
pour les droits des femmes et de vouloir
inscrire la liberté de recourir à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la
Constitution je suis fier de lutter pour
de nouveaux droits et notamment le droit
de mourir dans la dignité cette majorité
ce gouvernement c'est celui du progrès
celui de la conquête de nouveaux droits
de l'émancipation pour chacun depuis
2017 sous l'autorité du Président de la
République c'est ce qui nous anime et
cela le
restera mesdames et messieurs les
députés vous me connaissez en 2017 j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être élu sur ces bans
j'ai été membre du gouvernement j'ai
travaillé avec vous alors vous le savez
malgré les tentatives de certains je ne
me laisserai jamais intimider jamais
intimidé par les motions de censure
préventiv jamais intimidé par l'écrit je
ne me laisserai jamais déstabilisé par
les hurlements et les injures rien ne me
détournera du cap du dialogue et des
solutions alors devant vous je veux
prendre trois engagements le premier je
m'engage à toujours garder ma porte
ouverte pour la discussion et la
recherche d'accord depuis 2022 à déjà
plus de 50 reprises nous avons prouvé
qu'il était possible de dépasser
l'éclivage au service des Français nous
avons prouvé que cette législature ne
serait pas celle de l'immobilisme avec
mon gouvernement nous voulons agir au
côté de tous les parlementaires chercher
sur chaque texte des majorités dans le
respect des convictions de chacun je
l'ai montré avec les dialogues de Bercy
je l'ai montré comme ministre de
l'éducation nationale je suis prêt à
échanger avec chacun sans a priori ni
arrièrepensé je crois que l'avenir de la
France vaut plus que les querelles
partisanes alors je serais toujours à
l'écoute et je répondrai toujours
présent pour bâtir des solutions
communes mais vous mesdames et messieurs
les députés partisans de la censure
permanente serez-vous au rendez-vous du
dialogue avoir des convictions ce n'est
pas refuser la construction de mon côté
avec mon gouvernement avec la majorité
nous sommes toujours prêts au dialogue
nous le voulons et notre porte sera
toujours ouverte ensuite je m'engage à
toujours respecter le Parlement et le
débat d'idée dans cet hémicycle la
République s'est forgé dans cet
hémicycle nous avons conquis des droits
et acquis des libertés C hémicycle
raisonne encore les mots des grands
débats qui ont fondé notre pays alors je
ne me résous pas à ce que dans cet
hémicycle résonne désormais le vacarme
et le Brouis permanent respecter le
Parlement c'est d'abord respecter les
orateurs tous les orateurs chacun ici
est
légitime chacun ici a le droit de
s'exprimer et d'être
entendu collectivement nous avons un
rôle à tenir car si on s'écoute pas au
Parlement si la violence verbale s'y
banalise pourraiton prétendre à
l'apaisement et au respect dans la
société alors avec la majorité avec mon
gouvernement nous veillons toujours au
respect de chacun à la bonne tenue des
débats à ce que le travail parlementaire
puisse être à la hauteur de ce que les
Français attendent nous nous sommes
engagés dès 2017 autour de la
bienveillance et malgré vos tentatives
vous ne nous conduirez jamais à nous
livrer à ce à quoi vous vous livrez
c'est-à-dire l'invective permanentes les
cris et les hurlements contre les
orateursz au rendez-vous renoncerez-vous
à faire de l'outrance un titre de gloire
accepterez-vous de proposer des
solutions et d'en débattre dans le
respect des convictions de chacun
accepterez-vous de confronter les idées
plutôt que de multiplier les excès et
les hurlements enfin mesdames et
messieurs les députés je prends
l'engagement de toujours respecter nos
institutions et toujours défendre nos
principes démocratiques cela va de soi
c'est au cœur même de notre action
depuis
2017 vous répétez sans cesse que nous
n'avons pas de majorité absolu ce n'est
ni un secret ni une nouveauté c'est une
situation qui est rare mais qui n'est
pas inédite sous la 5e République une
situation qui a toujours soulevé des
débats mais qu'une constitution solide
approuvée par le peuple français a
permis de surmonter sans jamais mettre
notre démocratie en danger une situation
qui n'a pas empêché des réformes
majeures comme la création des CHU ou 30
ans plus tard celle du RMI une situation
qui ne nous empêche pas et ne nous
empêchera pas d'avancer au service de
nos concitoyens vous demandiez un vote
vous l'aurez dans quelques minutes mais
alors en accepterez-vous son résultat je
m'interroge car 2 ans après certains
crient encore à l'usurpation de majorité
et refuse encore d'accepter leur
défaites aux élections présidentielles
et
législatives la réalité c'est que les
Français nous ont confié un mandat
démocratique pour gouverner et trouver
des majorités texte par texte ce mandat
avec mon gouvernement nous allons le
tenir nous allons le respecter pour les
énergies renouvelables pour le partage
de la valeur dans l'entreprise pour les
moyens de notre justice et ceux de nos
armées pour le nucléaire pour nos
agriculteurs pour une santé renforcé un
accès aux soins renforcé pour nos
concitoyens et la semaine dernière
encore pour inscrire la liberté de
recourir à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse dans la Constitution nous
avons été CAPAES de trouver des
solutions qui ont rallié des voies
au-delà des clivages y compris sur les
bancs de la gauche je n'ai aucun doute
que nous y parviendrons encore et avec
mon gouvernement je n'y renoncerai
jamais mesdames et messieurs les députés
je crois au débat à la recherche
d'accord je crois au respect des
orateurs comme des idées je crois aussi
à l'action à la détermination au
résultats pour les Français avant même
que j'ai prononcé ma déclaration de
politique générale vous avez choisi de
tenter de censurer mon gouvernement cela
ne m'arrêtera pas ni dans ma volonté
d'agir ni dans ma volonté de dialoguer
j'ai entendu l'appel des Français avec
mon gouvernement je suis déterminé à
répondre à leurs attentes à leurs
inquiétudes à leurs doutes
avec mon gouvernement je mettrai toutes
mes forces dans la bataille toutes mes
forces pour convaincre et construire des
majorité car il en va de l'avenir de la
France et des Français je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est à Madame Luquet
pour le groupe démocrate pour une durée
de 15
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues vous avez finalement patienté
presque un mois avant de déposer votre
première motion de censure de l'année je
m'interroge encore sur les raisons de
cette motion certes le gouvernement n'a
pas demandé de vote de confiance mais il
n'est pas nécessaire d'être Premier
ministre pour savoir compter et pourtant
il faut bien faire avancer le pays c'est
ce que nous faisons gouvernement et
majorité relative donc nous avançons
malgré vous nous avons réformé le marché
du travail pour favoriser le retour au
plein emploi rétablir l'équilibre du
régime des retraites pour les prochaines
décennies améliorer notre politique
environnementale et énergétique donner
des moyens d'action à notre armée notre
police et nos hôpitaux faciliter le
retour des usines dans nos territoires
engager un plan contre les fraudes
fiscales et sociales augmenter nos
enseignants apporter des réponses à nos
agricultures à nos agriculteurs tout
n'est pas parfait nous restons persuadés
au groupes démocrate que les débats au
sein de cet hémicycle peuvent être
constructifs et aboutir à des consensus
bénéfiques pour les français pour autant
nous ne pensons pas nécessairement la
même chose à l'image de nos concitoyens
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui fait notre
richesse mais ce n'est pas parce que
nous ne pensons pas la même chose que
nous devons nous opposer de manière
stérile les uns aux autres dans une une
forme de Comédia de l'art et mise en
scène et mal mise en scène notre
responsabilité collective est d'échanger
nos vu et nos arguments pour arriver à
la meilleure solution possible pour
notre pays en tous les cas de tout faire
pour y parvenir il y a même des textes
pour lesquels nous étions quelque peu
sceptiques au départ qui peuvent aboutir
mon groupe a insisté avant Noël pour
inscrire enfin la proposition de loi sur
les cabinets conseil écr écrite par les
opposition au Sénat en désaccord avec le
texte de départ nous avons pensé que ce
débat devait avoir lieu résultat
l'examen en séance la semaine dernière
mené par un rapporteur communiste et un
rapporteur démocrate a permis d'avancer
sur ce sujet certes imparfa
imparfaitement mais la navette fera son
œuvre oui nous pouvons et nous devons
discuter de tout même comme cela vient
d'un camp qui n'est pas le nôtre
visiblement vous pensez exactement le
contraire et toute construction avec
certains groupes St vous a dès le départ
à l'échec quand ça ne vient pas de vous
pourtant nous avons à faire pour les 3
années à venir comme le disait notre
président de groupe la semaine dernière
pour redonner
à la France sa force pour redonner aux
Français l'envie d'être unis solidaire
leur redonner confiance dans leur avenir
et celui de leurs
enfants nous avons une chance inouie de
vivre dans notre pays celui des
solidarités à chaque étape de la vie où
chacun peut être soigné où chacun a
accès à une éducation gratuite de
qualité mais nous devons nous adapter en
permanence à ce monde qui évolue les
solutions de 1997 de 2007 voire même
dans certains cas de 2017 ne sont pas ou
plus forcément celles dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui loin des basses
querelles politiciennes les Français
nous attendent ils nous attendent pour
redonner les moyens à l'école de
préparer correctement les nouvelles
générations parce qu'elles sont notre
avenir celui de notre pays poursuivons
le travail pour que cette école
redevienne celle de la promesse
républicaine de l'émancipation de
l'ascenseur social vous l'avez dit la
semaine dernière monsieur le Premier
ministre il faut revoir le système de
formation des professeurs leur redonner
confiance à eux aussi pour qu'ils aient
envie d'enseigner qu'ils y trouvent leur
compte pas que d'un point de vue
financier et que l'école attire de
nouveaux talents pour cela il faut aussi
penser autrement le système être
davantage à l'écoute de ce qui
fonctionne savoir ouvrir à tous les
possibilités d'explorer de nouvelles
pistes d'enseignement s'adapter au temps
nouveau les Français nous attendent
aussi pour adapter notre système de
santé depuis 6 ans les efforts
financiers humains technologiques n'ont
pas manqué je pense par exemple au
numérus closusus nous avons réalisé ce
que trois ou quatre génération de
ministre et députés aurent dû faire
c'est-à-dire l'ouvrir nous sommes
convaincus au groupe démocrate
qu'investir aujour'hu dans notre
jeunesse cette part qui rêve de soignant
est un investissement d'avenir même si
cela demande des moyens conséquents nous
ne devons pas compter sur les autres
pays confrontés aux mêmes difficultés
que nous pour compenser les décennies
d'égarement il y aurait bien d'autres
points à développer sur ce sujet mais
les textes viendront où nous pourrons en
débattre j'en suis certaine monsieur le
Premier ministre nous devons aussi
conforter notre pays sur le plan
écologique bien sûr que ce combat nous
pour le cléat et l'environnement est
mondial mais nous devons poursuivre
aussi au niveau national ce que nous
avons entomé depuis 6 ans parce que les
les résultats sont là je crois
sincèrement que c'est l'un des domaines
où nous avons le plus avancé les
chiffres le démontrent trimestre après
trimestre sur les 6 premers mois de
l'année 2023 les émissions sont en
baisse de plus de 4 % par rapport à 2022
nous rapprochant de plus en plus des
objectifs ambitieux que nous sommes
fixés autre point celui de la crise
violente de l'immobilier que nous
traversons pourtant le budget qui est
consacré au logement est colossal 40
milliards d'euros davantage que chez nos
voisins européens ainsi je crois que
nous croyons jerois et nous croyons au
groupe démocrate qu'il faut une certaine
remise à plat en posant toutes les
questions celle du financement du
foncier des économies d'énergie duusan
de la transformation des bureaux et
bâtiments VI en logement de la fiscalité
ou encore des
allocations sur l'emploi nous avons
réussi à atteindre le taux de chômage le
plus bas depuis 40 ans grâce aux
réformes lancées en 2017 nous nous nous
en réjouissons mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous résoudre à accepter que plus de 7 %
de la population active soit condamné au
chômage certains retrouveront un emploi
rapidement ou en profiteront pour lancer
leur propre activité mais d'autres enfin
sont au chômage depuis longtemps et plus
ils y restent plus il rest ils risquent
d'ici enfermé pour cela notre volonté
est double simplifier les règles
d'employabilité et d'assurance chômage
pour atténuer les craintes de
potentielles employeurs tout en
continuant à les former davantage pour
les aider à trouver demain l'emploi qui
leur correspond cet enjeu de formation
ne sert pas qu'à prévenir le chômage de
longue durée c'est aussi peut-être
surtout un enjeu de pouvoir d'achat le
reste à vivre de ceux qui travaillent
n'est souvent pas suffisant au regard
des efforts
engagés notre objectif est simple faire
que le travail P mieux cela passe bien
sûr par une revue des prélèvements sur
le travail mais cela ne fera pas tout
nous devons continuer de développer
notre économie c'est ce qui fera notre
richesse de demain ce qui fait notre
richesse aussi je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est notre système de
solidarité pour ne laisser personne au
bord de la route cela doit être
particulièrement le cas pour nos
familles et nos enfants nous nous ne
pouvons nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
ambitieux en matière de politique
familiale les congés parentaux ne sont
pas forcément adaptés trop long pour
certains enfin surtout certaines qui
s'éloignent alors de l'emploi avec des
conséquences dramatiques pour leur suite
de leur carrière trop court pour
d'autres qui ne partagent alors pas
suffisamment les bouleversements de
l'arrivée d'un enfant au sein d'un
couple les modes de garde doivent être
aussi développés en laissant la liberté
aux parents de s'organiser en fonction
de ce leur qui leur de ce que leur ce
qui leur convient le mieux pardon
l'accompagn
financier par la société doit lui aussi
être revu et élargi à l'ensemble des
familles dans ce contexte une attention
particulière en matière de revenus de
logement d'alimentation doit être
apporté aux familles monoparentales qui
sont aujourd'hui les les plus concerné
par la précarité ces femmes car ce sont
principalement des femmes et ces enfants
nécessitent que nous nous engagions
davantage en leur faveur j'espère
monsieur le Premier ministre que votre
gouvernement proposera prochainement des
mesures en la matière enfin tout cela ne
sera possible qu'avec des finances
publiques saines la capacité à réformer
dépend avant tout de la crédibilité d'un
état notamment de ses finances publiques
par exemple nous ne pourrons répondre
efficacement à la dette climatique sans
nous attaquer à l'enjeu de la dette
publique tant les investissements en
matière
environnemental sont importants pour le
groupe démocrate la dette n'est pas
forcément une mauvaise chose si elle est
productive à long terme parce que la
dette utile d'aujourd'hui c'est celle
que nous laissons filer sur nos dépenses
quotidiennes de fonctionnement et la
dette que nous ne pourrons pas lever
demain pour financer ce qui sera alors
nécessaire voilà en quelques mesdames et
messieurs de l'opposition chers
collègues tout ce qui tout ce qui tout
ce sur quoi pardon nous pourrons
travailler ensemble si vous acceptiez le
principe du débat démocratique avant de
penser avant tout à vous
opposer votre posture est telle qu'avant
même de que ce nouveau gouvernement ne
commence à travailler vous voulez le
sanctionner si vous aviez la capacité en
vous alliant à d'autres de constituer
une majorité alternative cela se
comprendrait mais de la même façon qu'un
premier ministre c'est compter une
députée c'est aussi le faire vous n'en
avez pas les moyens votre démarche est
ainsi une n une nouvelle fois veine
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous le
savez vous pouvez compter sur notre
groupe pour travailler avec vous vous
accompagnerz dans votre énergie votre
volonté de réformer le pays nous vous
accompagnerons avec les espoirs que nous
portons nos valeurs et notre combativité
aussi bien sûr nous ne voterons pas
cette motion de censure je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues vous allez commenter ch
intervention monsieur le Président Valot
pour le groupe socialiste vous avez la
parole pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes oh ben comme
toujours il a beaucoup d'ATT je va
essayer de pas vous
décevoir monsieur le premier
ministreême pas si je dis madame la
Présidente directement comme ça me
retournant vers vous parce que vous le
méritiez merci Monsieur le le Premier
ministre il n vous aura pas fallu
longtemps pour avoir un mauvais bilan
vous avez cette semaine renoncer plan au
plan écofyo sacrifier l'avenir au
prisant mis dos à dos la question
environnementale et la question agricole
bal tragique à Matignon de mort
l'agriculture et la santé vous n'êtes
pas un visionnaire Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous êtes un démagogue vous
avez cette semaine pour le 70e
anniversaire de l'appel de l'abé pierre
réussi le tour de force de saper la loi
SRU et son objectif de mixité sociale
dans l'habitat déjà lourdement fragilisé
vous qui parlez de réarmement civique
vous allez donner une prime à la
canaille à celles et à ceux qui depuis
des années ne respectent pas la loi vous
avez cette année augmenté de près de 10
% le tarif de l'électricité alors que la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie en
suggéré la baisse alourdissant ainsi les
factures de 153 € en moyenne pour un
couple vivant dans 50 m² vous ne voulez
pas que le travail paye pour vivre mais
qu'il paye vos vos factures vous avez
cette semaine encore mis les enseignants
dans la rue et réussi à faire
démissionner le recteur de l'académie de
Paris et a enterrer avec lui une réforme
visant à introduire plus de mixité
sociale en classe préparatoire vous
n'êtes pas le premier ministre des
Classes moyennes vous êtes celui des
classes
affaires vous avez cette semaine réussi
à pénaliser encore les travailleurs
seniors en annonçant la suppression de
laallocation Spécifique de Solidarité de
nombreuses personnes en situation de
grande vulnérabilités vont être victimes
de vos choix budgétaires tandis que vous
en ferez supporter le poids au
département
vous venez d'arriver monsieur le Premier
ministre il est déjà temps de partir car
nous savons que vous ne nettoierez pas
ce que vous aurez sali et que vous ne
réparerez pas ce que vous aurez cassé
mais comme vous attaché à la vérité je
veux reconnaître sur un point que vous
avez tenu
parole tous les organes qui ne se sont
pas réunis ces 12 derniers mois seront
supprimés disiez-vous et vous avez joint
l'acte à la parole en disolvant
définitivement votre hémisphère gauche
monsieur le Premier ministre comme comme
Bruno Le Maire semble-t-il qui n jamais
avir d'un mensonge d'une approximation
vous êtes né en
1989 cela ne vous empêche pas de
regarder l'avenir avec de vieilles
lunettes vous avez vos réformes du
marché du travail du RSA de l'assurance
chômage faites de mauvaises idées et de
mauvais coup sont de véritables fabriqu
à travaille à travailleurs pauvres elles
ont 40 ans plus vieilles que vous et
elles sentent la
naftaline votre priorité est claire
disiez-vous favoriser le travail qu'il
paye toujours mieux que l'inactivité
vous voulez désmicardiser la France vous
qui avez continuement refusé les coups
de pouce et envisagé depuis 2017 une
réforme de son indexation sur
l'inflation que vous Jez trop généreuse
en fait nous ne comprenons plus votre
projet s'agit-il d'augmenter les
salaires ou de freiner le SMIC monsieur
le Premier ministre nous voulons que le
travail paye et qu'il paye bien voilà
pourquoi nous voulons que la valeur
change de camp qu'il ne soit plus du
côté du capital des rentiers des
héritiers des actionnaires et des
rémunérations extravagantes de celles et
de ceux auquels vous avez consenti tous
les cadeaux et réservé tous les
privilèges depuis 2017 c'est privilégié
du séparatisme social mais du côté du
travail des travailleurs des classes
populaires laborieuses qui n'ont que
leur force de travail pour vivre et qui
parfois n'en vivent pas je vous parle
des caissières des ouvriers de
l'agroalimentaire des artisans du
bâtiment des infirmières des professeurs
de celles et de ceux que nous avons
applaudit à 20h et auquel vous faites
payer aujourd'hui le quoi qu'il en coûte
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour notre
part ne croyons pas au privilégiés d'en
bas ce qui est en jeu c'est le juste
partage de la valeur entre le capital et
le travail dont il faut égaliser
l'imposition en supprimant la flat taxe
en rétablissant l'ISF en taxant les
multinationales qui consolident 40 % de
leurs résultats dans les paradis fiscaux
nous voulons également une juste
distribution des revenus entre les
salariés et les actionnaires comme entre
les salariés eux-mêmes en limitant les
écart de rémunération de 1 à 20 pour
retrouver ce que Orwell appelait la
décence commune songez que seulement
0,32 % des salariés en France gagnent
plus de 12 fois le SMIC et que si nous
redistributions cette masse salariale
nous pourrions augmenter de 233 € nets
par mois 20 % des salariés les plus
modestes nous ne répondrons pas à la
question des salaires si N répondons pas
à cette réalité injuste et imp
implacable les PME payent les impôts des
multinationales qui ne les payent pas
les classes moyennes payent les impôts
des hyper riches qui ne les payent pas
vous défendez la valeur travail nous
défendons la valeur du travail nous
voulons la reconnaissance de l'utilité
sociale comme mesure de la valeur du
travail dans l'emploi et hors emploi
nous voulons la reconnaissance du
travail gratuit et nous considérons que
l'heure est venue d'une radicale
reconsidération moral et économique des
métiers du soin et du lien d'un modèle
économique fondé sur la production de
l'humain de l'humanité par l'humain au
seuil de grandes mutations démographique
face au défi du grand âge au cœur d'une
révolution numérique et de
l'intelligence artificielle qui n'a
donné à voir qu'une part d'elle-même et
qui bouleversera les organisations du
travail nous avons plus que besoin des
infirmières des aides à domicile des
auxiliaires de vie des assistants
d'éducation des aides soignantes
laissons aux machines le travail des
machines et rendons aux humains le
travail humain qu'est-ce qui fait la
valeur ce dont nous ne pouvons pas nous
passer nous voulons en définitive bâtir
un modèle économique pour le 21e siècle
où le travail n'est plus au service
exclusif du PIB mais de la vie large
comme disait jores et de la plain santé
ces métiers essentiels sont au cœur des
problématiques de genre et des logiques
de ségrégation voici voilà les combats
jamais achevés qui doivent être les
nôtres les femmes et les travailleurs
étrangers sont surreprésentés avec des
bass salaires des temps partiels subis
et du travail fragmenté qui aliment la
pauvreté laborieuse vous avez annoncé
que les personnels d'entretien de
l'administration qui le souhaitent
pourrai travailler aux horaires de
bureau fort bien sauf que l'essentiel et
que ces personnels travaillent pour
l'essentiel dans entreprises privées et
que vous trouvez la matière à nouveau à
des économies et que la convention du
nettoyage prévoit un seuil de 16 he
hebdomadaire minimum une fois de plus
vous semblez faire mais comme toujours
vous faites semblant vous nous parlez
d'emploi pour ce qui nous concerne nous
voulons parler de travail si central
dans nos vies personnelles comme dans
nos sociétés le travail comme activité
humaine par laquelle les travailleurs
transforme le monde naturel et social et
transformment eux-mêmes nous voulons
parler du maltavail des conditions de
travail je vois que vous rivez riez à
cet instant des vies qui abîment les
corps les âmes font des malades et des
morts monsieur le Premier ministre mais
tout cela dans l'indifférence de votre
absence d'écoute d'une opposition à
laquelle vous avez prétendu tendre la
main vous êtes sour à ce que l'on peut
vous dire sur un sujet dont avez
prétendu qu'il était central de votre
travail sans menacer par l'organisation
du travail oui certains des travailleurs
perdent le goût et le sens du travail le
sens perdu du travail voilà enjeu à la
confluence de l'utilité sociale de la
cohérence éthique et de la
réhabilitation de soi le travail comme
une communauté mise au service des
causes commune de but partager ceux
d'une nation et d'une entreprise le
Premier ministre continuant de discuter
avec ses collègues plutôt d'écouter le
l'opposition qui lui parle de travail ce
qui est censé être le cœur de son sujet
le sens du travail monsieur le Premier
ministre pourrait devenir le terrain de
nouvelle conquête social remettant en
cause les rapports de domination et les
organisations il continue de regarder
son téléphone portable alors qu'ici vous
vous êtes les témoins accablés du peu
d'intérêt que le gouvernement et le
Premier ministre pte à l'opposition et
au débat parlementaire nous défendons la
nécessité de participer à l'organisation
du travail pour ne pas subir le travail
prescrit qui fait le travail mort et la
perte de sens et nous ne voulons pas non
plus loin de vos caricatures sur le
droit à la paresse penser séparément le
temps de travail et le travail libéré
qui doit être aussi un temps de
citoyenneté active d'éducation populaire
et despénouissement personnel vous avez
supprimé les CHSCT nous défendons le
dialogue social l'institution du
dialogue professionnel et la
codétermination dans l'entreprise sur
dont il faut se débarrasser outre vous
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ce n'est
pas du travail mais des rapports de
domination voilà pourquoi toujours dans
l'indifférence puisque vous continuez de
discuter avec vos voisins de derrière
loin du réarmement civique de la
recivilisation vous continuez par votre
attitude même d'être le symbole d'un
mépris dont vous saviez que vous ne vous
départiriez pas voilà pourquoi nous
luttons contre libéralisation contre le
retour du tacheronnage préindustriel et
que nous défendons la présemption de
salariat pour les travailleurs de des
plateformes hier comme aujourd'hui nous
devons toujours mieux civiliser le
travail vous n'aspirez qu'à le
libéraliser Monsieur le Premier Ministre
occupé à rire avec vos ministres alors
que 152 travailleurs sont morts dans
notre pays l'année dernière que les
maladies professionnelles explose que la
pleine santé au travail devrait être
l'un de vos objectifs vous préférez
continuer de vapoter et de papoter
Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
discours sur le travail est un discours
à courte vue une vue courte et de
vieilles lunettes disais-je les Français
ne vous font pas confiance pour conduire
le pays nous ne vous font pas confiance
pour tenir le volant voilà pourquoi nous
voterons cette motion de défiance je
vous remercie évidemment pour l'intérêt
soutenu que vous avez manifesté à nos
propos nous savons à quel point vousz
construction au dialogue à la recherche
du compromis que vous tirerez toutes les
conséquences et toutes les conclusions
de ce parlementarisme de fait issu des
urnes du pluralisme qui peut-être dans
l'histoire la source de grandes lois de
ces lois immortelles dont la trè
République souvent décrié mais qui était
un régime parlementaire auquel nous
tenons a été dans l'histoire capable je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
[Musique]
Président la parole est
àame pour le groupe
[Musique]
horizon merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
Messieurs les ministre chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous n'aviez pas encore prononcé votre
déclaration de politique générale dans
cette hémicycle mardi dernier qu'une
motion de censure avait déjà été déposée
par les députés de la
uni comme rarement pour ce grand
événement cadeau de bienvenue diront
certains étonnant quoi que je dois tout
de même reconnaître que sur ce coupl-à
nos collègues sont extrêmement créatifs
ils ont inventer la censure CR
préventive ou créative préventive
permettant de renouveler un genre qu'il
maîtrise à la perfection nul besoin de
réagir à votre discours la censure
préventive permettent s'en extraire sans
difficulté nul besoin d'attendre les
premières annonces les premières
orientations de la politique que vous
souhaitez mener et les premiers actes la
censure préventive facilite la tâche
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
souhaitez affronter pour avancer comptez
sur nous les partisans du censurer pour
tout bloquer en auront pour leur compte
car le temps est à l'action alors qu'une
partie du pays est en proie aux doutes
aux colères et au C Vous avez présenté
votre feuille de route mardi une feuille
de route claire autour de trois volontés
désmicardisé débureaucratisé et
déverrouillé notre pays dispose de de
formidable véritables atouts qu'il nous
faut continuer à mettre en valeur les
bonnes volontés sont légion et ne
demande qu'à être libéré les
agriculteurs présents dans les
mobilisations ces derniers jours nous
l'ont dit ils ne demandent pas l'omon il
demande qu'on leur permette de vivre
dignement de leur travail qu'on arrête
de les fliquer de les traiter comme de
potentiel danger et qu'on les considère
simplement pour ce qu'ils sont des
hommes et des femmes qui nous permettent
de nous nourrir à l'image des
agriculteurs ce sont les artisans les
commerçants les élus locaux quasiment
tous les Français qui nous demandent
d'en finir avec des réglementations dont
ils ne comprennent pas la logique qu'il
considèr parfois comme contradictoire
voire inique qui brideent les
initiatives complique le quotidien et
conduisent parfois à des situations sans
queue ni tête il ne s'agit dès lors pas
de sa'abrer aveuglément dans les normes
de les supprimer au simple motif
qu'elles sont des normes ce que nous
demandent nos concitoyens c'est de
remettre du bon sens et de la confiance
au cœur de la politique le bon sens ce
n'est pas un gros mot ce n'est pas
l'arbitraire non plus le bon sens c'est
le retour à des politiques publiques à
hauteur d'hommes qui sont ancré dans le
quotidien de nos concitoyens pour les
servir pas pour les fliquer pour leur
permettre de vivre paisiblement ensemble
pas pour leur empoisonner la vie le cri
du cœur de nos agriculteurs est
transposable dans tous les pans de notre
société et pour le secteur agricole
comme pour les autres chacun doit
assumer ses responsabilités si l'Union
européenne est responsable d'une part de
l'inflation normative l'État ne peut se
cacher derrière son petit doigt les
surtranspos
ne sont pas une exigence de Bruxelles
les collectivités ne sont pas en reste
même si elles ont fait des efforts le
législateur que nous sommes doit
également interroger sa façon de
légiférer nous devons nous astreindre
autant que possible à construire et
voter des lois claires simples et
lisibles sans nous perdre dans les
détails les plus absurdes tout cela ne
doit pas rester un vœux pieux mais se
traduire dans les actes par des lois
moins bavardes adapté aux besoins de nos
citoyens libérer les énergies c'est
aussi permettre à chacun de vivre
dignement de son travail trop de
Français ont la mère sentiment que la
différence de niveau de vie entre ceux
qui travaillent et ceux qui ne
travaillent pas n'est pas à la hauteur
de leurs investissements de leur
sacrifice parfois ils ont l'impression
de beaucoup payer pour les autres et de
recevoir trop peu
desmicardiser la France c'est dire à
chacun de nos compatriotes qu'ils
vivront dignement de leur travail que
s'ils fournissent les efforts ils en
récolteront les fruits notamment par le
salaire surtout c'est dire que si le
SMIC est un progrès social il ne peut et
ne doit pas être la seule perspective
d'une carrière professionnelle enfin
c'est tenir la promesse que lorsque l'on
travaille on ne peut pas être en
situation de pauvreté financière ce
n'est plus tolérable l'impression de
contribuer beaucoup et mêler à celle de
ne pas recevoir assez le sentiment que
malgré un niveau d'imposition élevé une
dépense publique parfois des plus élevé
au monde et des finances publiques à la
corde on ne sait pas vraiment où va son
argent nous devons lutter pied à pied
contre la dégradation de certains
services publics rappelez aussi que
beaucoup a d'ors et déjà été fait pour
réarmer le régalien et les services
publics essentiel mais tout cela prend
du temps et le sous-investissement
chronique dans certains services publics
depuis des années laisse des traces
tenaces de la même façon la transition
écologique qui est le défi de notre
siècle nécessite des investissements
massifs et des mesures courageuses et
compréhensibles l'État n'est pas le seul
à mener ces grandes batailles il doit
embarquer les collectivités territorial
qui sont souvent un maillon pertinent et
efficace pour permettre l'accès à des
services publics de qualité pour se
faire il faut faire confiance aux élus
locaux qui ont une connaissance précise
de leur territoire et des besoins de
leur population là encore des solutions
de bon sens sont à même d'améliorer bien
des situations car elles sont prises au
plus près du terrain
la présentation avant 2025 d'un projet
de loi de simplification de l'action
publique locale est à souligner nous
formons le vœux qu'il soit coconstruit
avec et pour les élus locaux formidable
gardien de l'action publique partout en
France enfin et j'en termineraai par là
il nous faut continuer à restaurer
l'autorité à l'école bien sûr où vous
aviez annoncé un cap et des décisions
extrêmement claires lorsque vous étiez
rue Grenelle mais plus généralement
partout dans la société les millions de
Français qui respectent chaque jour les
règles ne supportent plus devir une
poignée d'individus s'en affranchir la
délinquence doit être réprimer avec
sévérité et les incivilités ne faire
l'objet d'aucune
menzuétude ce sont précisément ces
incivilité qui crèvent le pacte social
et nourrissent l'exaspération de nos
concitoyens ceux qui ne respectent pas
les règles essentiel à la vie en société
doivent se les voir rappeler avec
fermeté et les incivil c'est que les
jeunes messieur les nupes pourquoi vous
parlez des
jeunes c'est pas les incivilités c'est
pas que les jeunes la délinquence doit
être donc réprimée avec sévérité les
incivilités ne faire l'objet d'aucune
mensuétude ce sont précisément ces
incivilités qui grèvent le pacte social
et nourrissent l'exaspération de nos
concitoyens ceux qui ne respectent pas
les règles essentielles à la vie en
société doivent se les voir rappeler
avec fermeté vous l'avez rappelé deç on
peu plus clair mardi dernier Monsieur le
Premier Ministre principe clair tu
casses tu répares et oui tu salis tu
nettoies et oui tu défi l'autorité on
t'apprend à le respecter il vous plaît
vous l'aurez compris nous nous
retrouvons pleinement dans les priorités
que vous avez énoncé et dans les grands
axes que vous souhaitez suivre la parole
é éclaire les actes doivent désormais la
traduire concrètement monsieur le
Premier ministre le groupe Horizon est
et sera à vos côtés pour permettre le
plein succès de votre politique pour la
réussite de la France et l'amélioration
des conditions de vie de nos concitoyens
je vous remercie merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Benjamin Lucas pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
le Premier ministre vous êtes né en
1989 Jordan Bardella est né en
1995 tous deux vous vous proclamez
porte-parole de notre génération faisant
de votre âge un fait politique soit je
suis né en 1990 alors permettez-moi de
faire irruption pour un instant dans ce
duel si souvent transformé en duo pour
vous é luui la jeunesse est un alibi
monsieur bardellaa veut ainsi faire
oublier qu'il dirige un parti vieux d'un
demi- siècle fondé par l'ancien
collaborateur des nazis animé depuis par
les obsessions identitaires les pulsions
racistes il est pourtant bel et bien à
la tête d'un vieux clan sous
surveillance de l'héritière monsieur
hatal votre parcours est l'aveu d'un
parti qui lui non plus ne revendique
aucune histoire aucune mémoire aucune
conviction et n'a donc d'autrre
boussolle que l'opportunisme érigé en
méthode de gouvern
la preuve pour moi la jeunesse est le
renouveau d'une histoire pass son dénis
oui nous nous reconnaissons dans un
clivage consubstantiel à notre
République entre la gauche et la droite
notre avantage par rapport à vous nous
entrons ici avec de siècles d'expérience
avec un héritage collectif et des
convictions qui obligent à l'humilité
dans cet héritage il y a au-dessus de
tout la République c'est la mission
historique de la gauche que de la
défendre quand elle est menacée de la
rétablir quand elle est effondrée mais
aussi de la revendiquer quand elle est
dévoyée au fond vous êtes monsieur hatal
le meilleur ami de Monsieur Bardella
plus vous disloquez le pacte républicain
construit autour de nos services publics
plus vous abîmez le contrat social et
les mécanismes qui l'ont préservé depuis
1945 plus vous agitez ici les thèmes et
les terme de l'extrême droite plus il y
a de place pour la discorde la fracture
au final la haine des Français les uns
contre les autres donc plus il y a de
place pour l'extrême
droite parfois même vous êtes le frère
jumeau de Monsieur Bardella jumeau on
l'a vu hier quand il il s'agit
d'influger du travail forcé aux
allocataires du RSA jumeau quand pour la
première fois depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale votre majorité a voté une loi
relative à l'immigration avec le soutien
de l'extrême
droite jumeau quand il s'agit de
reprendre les slogans de la chaîne de
Monsieur boloret et de lui offrir le
départ des rares ministres qui osent
dire la vérité à son sujet jumeau dans
votre conception de l'école et je veux
m'y attarder un instant parce qu'elle
est au cœur de la refondation de notre
pacte républicain vous et lui partagez
un même diagnostic sur les école c'est
le monde vu par ces news elle serait
pour vous l'école malade d'un manque
d'autorité mais la réalité c'est que
l'école est malade d'un manque d'égalité
l'école de notre pays c'est en effet
comme un hôpital qui soignerait très
bien les patients en bonne santé c'est
la reproduction sociale et c'est en fait
cette situation que vous voulez
amplifier car vous êtes habité par une
vision de la société et de l'école qui
est parfaitement bien résumée par le
président Macron lui-même d'un côté ceux
qui réussissent de l'autre ceux qui ne
sont rien votre vision de l'école c'est
celle qui consiste à considérer que la
réussite des meilleurs peut-être
entravée par ceux qui n'y arrivent pas
aussi bien de cette analyse procède
aussi la validation morale du
séparatisme scolaire du refus de la
mixité y compris de genre au plus haut
sommet du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale vous voyez la République et
son école comme un casino faisons
l'égalité des chances et advienne que
pourra alors moi j'assume face à vos
obsessions inégalitaires l'obsession de
l'égalité et nous nous refusons de
croire à vos fables d'une école d'entant
fantasmée nous voulons donner à l'école
la force de la promesse républicaine en
lui octroyant les moyens nécessaires
pour accomplir sa mission en repensant
la façon dont on enseigne et dont on
apprend en renforçant par l'éducation
populaire la culture le droit aux
vacances l'alliance éducative qui permet
à chaque élève de trouver confiance en
Lui vous êtes en train de casser notre
service public d'éducation pas après pas
marche après marche sans que la
représentation nationale puisse donner
son avis et encore moins son aval le
collège unique c'est apprendre ensemble
faire société ensemble ce n'est pas à
prendre séparément avec le même uniforme
dans le même lieu la décision de mettre
en place des groupes de niveau qui vont
assigner à résidence toute une
population d'élèves fragiles
majoritairement issu des catégories
populaires ne peut se faire par simple
décret nous vous demandons Monsieur le
Premier Ministre de sursoir à ce projet
pour permettre aux parlementaires de
pouvoir en débattre et de trancher la
question Monsieur le Premier Ministre
toville écrivait dans la démocratie
chaque génération est un peuple nouveau
la question qui disose dès lors à notre
génération c'est de savoir quel peuple
nous voulons être notre génération qui
est la première pleinement consciente du
péril mortel pour l'humanité que
représente le réchauffement climatique
pour laquelle a été inventé le concept
d'écoanxiété aspire à être le peuple
d'une république écologique où l'on ne
se bat pas pour l'accès à l'eau où l'on
retrouve le plaisir d'une nature
débarrassée des entrepôts géants et de
la bétonnisation à outrance notre
génération qui grandit dans la certitude
qu'elle vivra moins bien que les
précédents et fait plus que les autres
l'expérience de la précarité aspire à
être un peuple solidaire épris de
justice et d'égale dignité des êtres car
en effet ce n'est pas facile d'avoir 24
ans en 2024 notre notre génération
ouverte au monde qui vit la pluralité et
la diversité comme la grande richesse de
la nation aspire à être un peuple qui
vit en paix dans le respect de chacune
et chacun une société débarrassée du
racisme des discriminations du sexisme
de
l'homophobie notre génération la plus
informée et la plus connectée de
l'histoire aspire à être un peuple
citoyen dans une démocratie vivante
bouillonnante dans laquelle un président
de la République ne peut se passer du
consentement des électeurs ou leur
parlement mépriser les syndicats les
associations les contrepouvoirs locaux
ou le pouvoir judiciaire notre
génération qui est suffisamment adulte
aspire à être un peuple qui se construit
par la conviction plus que par
l'injonction elle ne veut pas de votre
service national obligatoire les valeurs
de la République ne s'apprennent pas
dans les caserne elles doivent
s'éprouver dans la vie quotidienne de
chacune et de chacun et je pense
notamment aux jeunes de nos quartiers
populaires notre génération aspire à
l'audace celle qui ouvre le champ des
possibles celle qui donne à la politique
et à l'engagement toute sa beauté vous
avez d'ailleurs achev votre discours de
politique générale en citant d'Anton de
l'audace encore de l'audace toujours de
l'audace mais Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de l'audace il en faut pour
abolir les privilèges pas pour les faire
perdurer de l'audace il en faut pour
engager la révolution écologique pas
pour céder au lobby de l'audace il en
faut pour penser à un autre modèle que
celui qui est obsédé par la croissance
et le profit pas pour tenter de faire
vivre sous perfusion le vieux modèle
productiviste les dogmes néolibéraux du
Millénaire dernier de l'audace il en
faut pour éradiquer la pauvreté et
partager les richesses pas pour
stigmatiser les plus pauvres et les
privés de droit au bonheur de l'audace
il en faut pour que l'on travaille mieux
moins et tous pas pour fliquer les
chômeurs négliger les souffrances au
travail et ne pas rémunérer dignement
celles et ceux qui n'ont que cette force
de travail pour vivre de il en faut pour
offrir à chaque Français un logement
digne pas pour démanteler la loi et ses
rues de l'ODACE il en faut pour protéger
les Français de l'inflation de ce
calvaire que devient chaque passage à la
caisse du supermarché pas pour minimiser
la réalité de leur difficultés où est
l'audace dans le macronisme de Monsieur
Atal votre nomination devait incarner
pour les cabinets de conseil qui
écrivent les éléments langage de votre
majorité le retour à cet esprit du
Nouveau Monde de 2017 quelle prétention
tout de même de s'arroger sans cesse le
mérite de nous faire changer d'époque la
Renaissance c'était autrement plus
disruptif comme vous pourriez dire qu'un
remadimement qui consacre le retour de
vieille gloire des gouvernements rafarin
auou Fillon où est l'audace dans le
leupénisme de Monsieur Bardella il
maquill leurs convictions pour mieux
duper les Français sur la réalité de
leur projet ils ne font ici que des
coups tactiques uniquement pour attraper
chaque colère qui
passe l'audace elle est chez celles et
ceux qui croient qu'un autre monde est
possible qui veulent agir à la racine
des désordres qui minent la société qui
veulent abolir la violence des
injustices la chape de plomb
inégalitaire qui étouffe le pays
l'audace plus que jamais c'est de
renouer avec le serment humaniste avec
la République sociale alors je dis en
cet instant et c'est une profession de
foi nous ne vous laisserons pas enfermer
la démocratie française dans ce tête à
tête mortifère pour la République que
vous mettez en scène avec Monsieur
Bardella nous nous serons au rendez-vous
des combats pour défendre les Français
face aux urgences de leur quotidien au
méfit de votre politique et nous nous
serons là le moment venu unis pour leur
proposer le projet qui relèvera les
grands défis de l'avenir de la
nation je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas sensu pour le groupe Gauche
démocrate et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesur
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres il me revient ici au nom du
groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine rassemblant les députés
communistes et progressistes ultrarin de
porter une voix singulière une voix qui
s'éteint pas devant les forces du marché
une voix qui au cours de l'histoire a
fait se rencontrer ceux qui croyaient au
ciel et ceux qui n'y croyaient pas une
voix qui n'a jamais cessé non seulement
de crier face aux injustices mais aussi
de proposer la justice afin que nos
principes et nos valeurs cessent d'être
dévoyé vous avez dit Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mardi dernier que nous av avion
la France en partage or depuis trop
d'années de recul en recul de casse de
l'assurance chômage en casse de la
retraite par répartition c'est la France
sans partage que vous insufflez une
France sans partage c'est celle qui
oublie son rôle sur la scène
internationale celle qui oublie bien que
membre du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
de porter partout dans le monde
l'exigence de fraternité et de paix de
Gaza en Ukraine du Soudan au Yémen
partout dans le monde la voix de la
France doit se confondre avec la paix
les mots du Grand Hugo nous le
rappellent homme que j'entrevois dans
l'assourdissement des trompettes
farouches plus fort que des lions et
plus vain que des mouches pour le
plaisir de qui vous exterminez-vous vous
n'avez qu'un seul droit celui de vous
aimer tous oui Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la fraternité c'est l'humanité
et face au DRAM qui se noue chaque jour
davantage à Gaza la France ne peut
accepter que la famine et les épidémies
soi orchestré comme une arme de guerre
qui confine à
l'inhumanité cette inhumanité qui vous a
conduit à transiger sur les tèes
d'extrême droite les plus indignes
acceptant de facto des disposition
reprenant la préférence nationale au
mépris de la vie d'enfants de femmes et
d'hommes qui risquent leur peau sur des
brafiux brvant les flots dans l'espoir
d'une vie meilleure fuyant les guerres
les famines les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique la colonisation
économique ou les persécutions
politiques une France sans partage c'est
celle qui accepte sans sourciller le
gllef de la finance qui règne mettant à
mal la route vers l'égalité 330000
personnes sont sans domicile fixes ce
nombre a doublé en 10 ans des milliers
d'enfants sont livrés à la rue chaque
soir venant percuter des promesses
présidentielles dévoyées et envoilé en
quelques années vous avez asséché notre
capacité collective à produire du
logement social Vous avez laissé
prospérer tous les ressorts de la
spéculation vous avez manqué le tournant
de la rénovation de l'habitat désormais
vous souhaitez amoindrir la loi de
solidarité et de rénovation urbaine
outil de cohésion et de mixité sociale
donnant un satisfait cite à ceux qui la
contournent depuis tant d'années
Monsieur le Premier Ministre un toit
c'est un droit mal loger des millions
d'habitants de notre pays c'est trahir
notre pacte
républicain une France sans partage
c'est celle qui instile le poison de la
division division entre salariés
chômeurs entre allocataires des minimas
sociaux et classe moyenne entre Français
et immigrés pourtant tout Cuxa seront
unis pour le paiement d'une facture
d'électricité qui va encore augmenter de
10 % ce mois-ci atteignant 44 % de
hausse en 2 ans tout cela du retraité à
l'enseignant du smicar au petits
commerçants du cadre moyen aux paysans
vont voir leur pouvoir de vivre rogné
par une inflation qui fait tant de mal
comment ne pas voir votre souci de la
division pour ne jamais pointer du doigt
les vrais profiteurs cette petite ce de
privilégiés qui parvient trop souvent à
rester sous les radars la plus belle des
ruses du diable est de vous persuader
qu'il n'existe pas écrivait Baudel la
plus belle des Russes des ultrriches est
de tenter de nous faire croire qu'il
n'existe pas pourrait-on paraphraser
tous milliardaires claironné Emmanuel
Macron comme projet de vie de notre
jeunesse il y a loin de la coupe aux
lèvres parce que pendant qu'on
illusionne la reproduction sociale
fonctionne à plein jusqu'à la caricature
au sein du gouvernement or une France
sans partage n'a pas d'avenir monsieur
le Premier ministre en moins de 3 ans
alors que vous piétinez le monde du
travail en le précarisant la fortune
cumulée des milliardaires à plus que
doublé atteignant plus de 1200 milliards
d'euros dans notre pays et comment
reférainez-vous cette indessence en
faisant trembler nos super profiteur
d'un froncement de sourcil voire même
parfois d'une mouille significative et
c'est tout les records de dividendes
versés près de 100 milliards d'euros
cette année les multiples dispositifs
pour échapper à l'impôt et transférer
tout ou partie de leur patrimoine dans
des contrées à fiscalité douce comme
l'ont dit les rachats d'action voilà ce
qui fait la France sans partage nous
avons principe à vous proposer tu te
casses avec tes dividendes tu paies et
on répare tu salis la France en partant
avec ta fortune dans un paradis fiscal
tu es taxé et on nettoi parce que
l'autorité qui confine à l'autoritarisme
ne s'applique pas à tous autoritaire
avec les petits et libéral avec les
puissants tel est votre crédo à
contrario de cette France sans partage
nous vrons pour une France du commun
notre pays est un pays riche immensément
riche qui s'est construit sur des
principes collectifs qui qui font notre
fierté il est encore temps de retisser
ce fil dans tous les domaines la santé
l'éducation la sécurité la tranquillité
publicque la souveraineté la solidarité
envers les plus fragiles ce qui compte
c'est la visée Monsieur le Premier
Ministre prenons la santé en exemple il
existe en la matière une alternative
avec ces deux branches celle que vous
poursuivez qui tente à accroître le
reste à charge pour les malades à
favoriser le privé plutôt que le public
a oubli la prévention c'est en quelque
sorte la peinture anglo-saxonne qui
vient flétrir notre tableau de la prise
en charge de la solidarité et puis il y
a l'autre branche celle qui consiste à
progresser vers 100 % SCU assis sur des
cotisations sociales pleines et entières
remettant en cause des milliards d'euros
d'exonération inefficace et permettant
ainsi que le demande les représentants
des personnels hospitaliers la
Fédération hospitalière de France un
véritable plan de reconquête de l'accès
aux soins pour tous annoncer ou
subodorer au cours de la même allocution
un élargissement des baisses de
cotisation social et une amélioration
des financements des besoins de la
protection sociale est juste une
illusion voire même rien qu'une
simulation monsieur le Premier ministre
comme pour les agriculteurs qui ont
besoin de prix rémunérateur qui ont
besoin de respect des mêmes règles et
normes entre les pays qui commercent les
salariés ont besoin d'être payés mieux
les salariés ont besoin d'être protégés
contre le dumping social les entreprises
notamment les PME ont besoin d'être
protéger contre le dumping fiscal ce
sont ces principes simples qui
permettront de redonner au pays de la
force et à nos habitants leur capacité à
construire ensemble à répondre aux
urgences écologiques sociales et
démocratiques faire communauté c'est
tout le contraire de ce séparatisme
social qui déferle sur des pans de notre
pays le débat sur l'école au-delà des
polémiques est un enjeu la question est
simple les moyens mis à disposition d'un
lycéen de félixboué à Cayenne ou ceux
d'un lycéen de Paul helloir à
Saint-Denis sont-ils les mêmes que ceux
d'un lycéen de Stanislas à Paris
sûrement pas il n'y a aucunement de
moyens et donc encore moins l'égalité de
traitement les enseignants ont su vous
le montrer jeudi dernier avec un
mouvement qui en appelle d'autres je
pourrais décliner cette démonstration à
l'envie notamment avec la catastrophe
qui vient de la présentation de cartes
scolaires dans le départements ayant
pour conséquence de véritables abandons
territoriaux votre défiance envers les
collectivités locales à qui vous essayez
de renier du pouvoir d'agir et de la
liberté sonne comme un péché originel
assurez à tous un égal accès au grand
service public régalien ou au service au
public a été non seulement négligé mais
dépeessé au risque de superposer
exclusion sociale et territoriale que ce
soit dans les quartiers populaires la
ruralité ou les territoires d'outremè
notre groupe portera plusieurs textes
d'initiative parlementaires pour exiger
le respect du droit commun partout dans
les territoires de la République avec
une commission d'enquête et des
propositions de loi qui visent au
respect de NS conitoyens des territoires
d' d'outr m monsieur le Premier ministre
avant de terminer je voudrais souligner
combien nous regrettons votre choix de
ne pas solliciter la confiance de
l'Assemblée nationale les petites
phrases parfois doucereuses sur le
respect du Parlement sur le respect des
des oppositions sur les portes ouvertes
ne sont que peu de poids face au 493
tonnes qui nous écrasent sans ménagement
respecter les parlementaires passera
nécessairement par la fin de cette
conduite addictive au 49 froid n'oubliez
pas que lorsque vous piétinez
l'assemblée monsieur le Premier ministre
c'est sur les Français que vous vous
essuyez les pieds
c'est parce que nous ne nous résignons
pas à cette société qui sombrerait dans
un autoritarisme social matiné de
libéralisme économique c'est parce que
nous ne nous résignons pas à cette
dérive qui fait le lit des ennemis de la
démocratie que nous vrons sans trembler
cette motion de censure seul acte pour
montrer notre défiance mais surtout
notre combativité et notre vigilance
pour faire triompher les espoirs et les
besoins d'un peuple uni entre l'avoir
l'être le savoir le faire le paraître et
le pouvoir absorbe toutes nos énergies
l'avoir l'emporte aujourd'hui car il
donne le pouvoir permet le paraître
domine le faire et dispense d'être et de
sooir pointer Edgar Pisani monsieur le
Premier ministre ne laissez pas la voir
l'emporter et emporter tout sur son
passage jusqu'à favoriser l'arrivé au
pouvoir des ennemis de la République et
de la démocratie je vous remercie je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à présent à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et territoire
bien Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous vivons
une situation politique inédite pour ne
pas dire presque une anomalie
démocratique puisque ce gouvernement
affronte une première motion de censure
alors même qu'il n'est pas encore
totalement constitué le scénario était
pourtant écrit par d'éminents stratèges
aid des de brillant communicquant
feuilletonner la composition du
gouvernement et tier cette séquence pour
montrer que le président reste le maître
du jeu politique mais cette belle
stratégie a été percutée par un
mouvement de colère agricole de grande
ampleur le maître des horloges s'est
torté à la réalité d'un pays fracturé
j'y reviendrai Monsieur le Premier
Ministre j'ai entendu votre volontarisme
l'action l'action l'action mais depuis 4
semaines c'est plutôt l'attente
l'attente l'attente en effet près d'un
mois après la démission d'éliisabeth
borne plusieurs champ ministériel
restent désespérément vacant dans une
sorte de latence du pouvoir
pas de ministre du Logement alors que
nous traversons une crise structurelle
et que nos concitoyens nous disent leur
difficultés à se loger nous avoir
entendu vos propositions sur la
simplification et l'accélération des
procédures cela suffira-t-il à enrayer
la crise cuide des modifications que
vous entendez apporter à la loi etu je
tiens à vous alerter si elles vont dans
le sens d'un détricotage sur l'impératif
de mixité de cohésion sociale pas de
ministres délégués aux outremes non plus
alors que ot connaît actuellement une
flambée de violence et comment venant de
ces territoires élonés de l'Hexagone ne
pas se sentir comme des Français de
seconde zone nous avons déjà eu trois
ministres on en annonce un 4è pourtant
nous continuons de demander à la fois de
prévoir une adaptation de chaque grand
projet des lois aux spécificités
ultramarines dès la conception des
textes mais aussi une grande loi de
programmation des outresmèes pas non
plus de ministre délégué de la santé ce
champ est en noyé dans le périmètre de
de trois anciens ministères pourtant
combien de fois avons-nous relié dans
cet hémicycle les inquiétudes de nos
concitoyens sur l'accès aux soins la
désertification médicale et la fermeture
des services
d'urgence nous avons alerté sur la
fatigue des soignants et des personnels
hospitaliier notre hôpital et plus
largement le système de santé est à bout
de souffle devant-nous attendre encore
une révolte pour agir nous avons pris
bonne notes de vos engagements un
service d'accès aux soins par
département la régularisation de
médecins étrangers ou le recrutement
d'assistants médicaux mais rien ou si
peu sur la trajectoire financière et sur
l'organisation de notre hôpital quant au
champ de l'éducation vous l'avez érigé
en priorité mais les polémques mais les
polémiques sans fin qui entourent la
ministre brouille le message deux
questions cependant la généralisation de
la généralisation de l'uniforme est-elle
la solution la mise en place de groupe
de nouveau au collège améliora-t-il le
niveau général soyons sérieux arrêtons
les communications à de bal et
travaillant sur le fond monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez évoqué un
gouvernement resserré pourquoi pas mais
un gouvernement vite car les chantiers
ne manque pas j'ajoute même que pour
rendre l'exercice plus complexe encore
que ces chantiers doivent être conduits
alors que notre déficit est un des plus
importants de la zone euro et que la
remontée des taux d'intérêt plane comme
une menace dans les prochains mois cela
ne vous a pas empêché de promettre une
baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards se rajoute
au 12 milliards d'économie également
prév vu alors où allez-vous faire des
coupes ces derniers jours les députés de
mon groupe ont longuement échangé et ont
fait le choix de ne pas voter pourtant
cette motion de censure nous restons
fidèles à notre créneau depuis 2022
celui d'incarner un groupe d'opposition
et de proposition nous ne nous
retrouvons pas dans les gesticulations
et la recherche du coup d'éclat
permanent nos concitoyens nous le disent
ils s'opposent à cette stratégie du
bruit et de la fureur ils veulent des
solutions équilibrées à leur difficultés
mais je le rappelle encore une fois que
les Français ont choisi de donner au
président et au gouvernement qu'une
majorité relative en faisant ce choix
ils vous enjoint de travailler
différemment moins verticalement avec
plus de concertation c'était d'ailleurs
la promesse qui avait été faite au
lendemain des élections législatives
elle n'a été que peu ou pas tenu par
votre prédécesseur c'est une méthode que
nous vous rappellerons tant qu'il le
faudra Monsieur le Premier Ministre
votre discours de politique générale qui
semble marquer une inflexion soulève à
minima des questions les premières
concernent bien évidemment les réponses
que vous apporter à la crise agricole
l'ampleur de la mobilisation révèle un
monde agricole acron les députés de mon
groupe ont pourtant alerté ces derniers
mois sur l'amancellement des norme sur
l'enfer administratif des aides PAC sur
les conséquences du règlement climatique
et la multiplication des crises je pense
notamment à la grippe aviaire sur
laquelle sétait mobilisé mon collègue
David topiaak nous avons aussi comme
beaucoup souligné l'insuffisance des
lois égalim pouréquilibrer les relations
commerciales et pour permettre
simplement à nos agriculteurs de vivre
de leur travail le gouvernement ne
semblait pas avoir forcément pris la
mesure des problèmes en témoigne la
faiblesse de votre projet initial de la
loi d'orientation agricole retiré en
catastrophe et qui sera renforcé nous
l'espérons tous depuis nous avons pris
connaissance de vos propositions ces
derniers jours pour éteindre l'incendie
dans ce contexte inflationniste actuel
votre recul sur le GNR est un
soulagement bienvenu nous avons des
interrogations sur les aides de la PAC
mais au-delà des mesures d'urgence elle
passe par davantage de décentralisation
et une simplification pour réduire les
délais d'attente qui sont aujourd'hui
incompressible je dois vous dire nos
réserves sur vos propositions quant au
réquilibrage des relations commerciales
davantage de contrôle oui mais cela ne
suffira pas tant que les causes sont
profondes il faut que cesse la pression
à la baisse sur les prix des matières
premières agricoles les députés du
groupe liad se sont également mobilisés
contre les grands accords de libre
échange qui introduisent une concurrence
déloyale et qui favorisent le moins
diant sociale et environnemental outre
l'abandon de l'accord avec le Mercosur
nous plaidons pour que la France fond à
l'échelle européenne la mise en place de
clauses miroir comme préalable à toute
discussion dans votre discours de
politique générale nous avons été par
contre surpris de la quasi absence de
proposition sur le pouvoir d'achat comme
si ce problème avait disparu de vos
radars pourtant la question de la vie
chè reste une des premières
préoccupations de nos concitoyens dans
l'Hexagone et dans les autres m
l'inflation ralenti certes mais les prix
ne baissent pas vraiment à ce titre j'ai
une question simple nous avons obtenu de
votre prédécesseur un élargissement du
chèque carburant au français des classes
populaires et moyennes qui utilisent
leur voiture bien qu'il é été inscrit au
budget 2024 il a été en partie remis en
cause par le ministre de l'Économie ma
question est donc simple Monsieur le
Premier Ministre quand cette mesure
entrera-t-elle en vigueur poser la
question du pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi
poser la question des salaires nous
avons relevé votre volonté et nous la
soutenons de
désmicartiser le pays les députés de mon
groupe se retrouvent pour que le travail
paye nous avons aussi pointé
l'écrasement de l'échelle des salairire
au niveau du SMIC des carrières passées
au SMIC ou rattrapé par le SMIC vous
avez annoncé une remise à plat du
système d'aide et d'exonération dans le
prochain budget c'est un chantier
d'ampleur vous nous trouverez à vos
côtés si cette réforme concilie deux
impératifs faciliter la progression des
salaires et financer le système de
protection sociale parler de travail
c'est aussi é voqué votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage il est probable que
vous porterez un nouveau durcissement
vous avez déjà annoncé la suppression de
Laas qui touche les chômeurs en fin de
droit nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à l'emploi des seigneurs comme
nous l'avons dit lors de la réforme des
retraites il nous faut un grand plat un
grand plan pardon sur l'emploi des
seigneurs je veux aussi vous mettre en
garde sur un raisonnement un peu
simpliste qui voudrait rendre les
demandeurs d'emploi responsables de l'
aaus intendu ces prochains mois du taux
de chômage dans notre pays autre
question vous avez évoqué le dispositif
de solidarité à la source en préparation
depuis de nombreux mois et dont la
concrétisation ne semble pas être une
priorité quand comptez-vous acheter
cette réforme ce ceci m'amène à l'un des
principaux mots dont souffre notre pays
la complexité et l'accumulation des
normes il y a quelques semaines j'ai
interrogé le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
la situation buesque que de
l'importation des armes et des munitions
à Saint-Pierre et miclon nous le savons
tous simplifier c'est complexe c'est un
travail de fourmis qui doit être mené
patiemment il y aura des modifications
législatives à apporter nous y serons
attentifs notamment dans le second
projet de loi industrie verte que vous
avez annoncé notre collègue Christophe
nagelen du reste président du groupe
d'étude sur la simplification
administrative est engagé sur ce
chantier un autre grand mal de notre
pays est son extrême centralisation
cette pratique si verticale du pouvoir
qui renforce le sentiment d'éloignement
que ressentent les Français il faut
décomplexier décomplexifier pardon tout
comme il faut décentraliser et
déconcentrer notre pays il faut aller
jusqu'à différencier adapter les normes
dans l'Hexagone comme dans les
outresmers je pense aussi à la Corse ou
un processus pour davantage d'autonomie
est en cours de discussion il doit
aboutir dans les prochains mois à une
réforme constitutionnelle c'est à ce
prix que nous combattrons à la fois la
défiance et la monté du sentiment
d'injustice qui traverse notre pays et
qui accroit les fractures les Français
ont le sentiment d'un pays à deux
vitesses d'une école à deux vitesses
d'un hôpital à deux vitesses d'un pays
qui n'est plus le même selon l'endroit
où l'on habite selon le milieu d'où l'on
vient Monsieur le Premier Ministre votre
tâche est ardue le contexte est
difficile et vous êtes aujourd'hui le
chef d'orchestre d'une majorité relative
personne ni aucun groupe n'a la vérité
absolue à vous donc d'écrire une
partition au nom de l'intérêt général de
tous les Français et les Françaises avec
le coûte et le respect de la diversité
politique qui s'exprime dans cet
hémicycle et qui traduit aussi les
fractures de notres pays je vous
remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole
pour le groupe Renaissance est à Madame
Caroline
Abadi
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues savez-vous ce
qui me fascine le plus chez les député
de la
nupess en toute circonstances en ver et
contre tous ils ont toujours raison
écoutez il le revendique même ici jamais
d'erreur toujours raison prenons
l'agriculture au hasard
ils ont voté contre égalim pemptoire ils
soutenaient l'interdiction immédiate des
phyos et aussi au passage les
délinquante saint Soline puis les
tracteurs sont arrivés sur l'autoroute
et tout à coup ils détiennent la
véritable cause à cette crise l'excès de
norme et n'hésite pas à réclamer
l'application stricte des lois égalim
qu'ils n'ont pas voté puis siôt les
tracteurs retournent au champ ils ont
encore raison ils sont les seuls à se
soucier de protéger la santé l'eau et la
terre rien que ça c'est un petit
monopole pour 3 semaines quand on a
toujours raison on a en toute circonstan
raison on se débarrasse très vite des
soucis de cohérence et
d'humilité dans la même logique ils sont
persuadés d'avoir eu raison de déposer
cette motion de censure contre votre
gouvernement votre première monsieur le
Premier ministre avant même votre
discours de politique
générale ça nous aura pas échappé non
plus ils ont déposé leurs motions avant
que vous exposiez au Parlement vos vos
priorités tenir plus encore les classes
moyennes renforcer l'offre de logement
libérer davantage le travail l'économie
accélérer la transition écologique mais
quand on a toujours raison difficile
d'être opposé à la création de 30000
logements en 3 ans opposé à la création
d'un service civique écologique opposé à
la solidarité à la source ou encore à la
baisse des charges pesant sur les
classes
moyennes comme ils savent tout ils savez
qu'il serait contre vos priorités avant
que vous ne les prononciez votre
première priorité la valeur travail qui
est au cœur de notre projet depuis 2017
de l'apprentissage à la retraite en
passant par la revalorisation des primes
d'activité et du SMIC plus 11 %. tout en
diminuant le chômage à son taux le plus
bas en 40 ans et de 10 points pour les
moins de 25 ans depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron a été élu président de la
République nous approuvons votre
diagnostic et vous soutiendrons pour
mettre fin à la trappe au bas salaire et
garantir aux travailleurs des revenus
supérieurs à ceux qui ne travaillent
pas sur sur le besoin d'autorité vous
mettez des mots sur des attentes fortes
les groupes parlementaires majoritaires
n'ont jamais légitimé la violence la
réparation par les casseurs est
indispensable vous voulez apporter une
réponse spécifique à cette
primodélinquence des moins de 16 ans
qu'on a découvert pendant les émeutes
vous pourrez vous appuyer sur la réforme
du Code de justice pénale des mineurs
dont on a vu l'efficacité en juillet
pour mettre en place ces travaux
d'intérêt éducatif et responsabiliser
les
parents sur la santé après plusieurs
décennies d'austérité nous avons avons
ouvert les vannes de la formation des
médecins plus 13 % de médecins formés
refinancer nos hôpitaux revaloriser les
soignants mais il reste tellement à
faire il reste tellement à faire vous
voulez continuer la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux en régularisant les
médecins étrangers présents en France en
recrutant 10000 assistants médicaux
faire de la santé mentale une grande
cause notamment parce que vous
reconnaissez l'échec du dispositif mon
soutien PSI pour la jeunesse
particulièrement vous voulez dans chaque
département un service d'accès aux soins
autant de mesures précieuses pour
préserver et améliorer notre système de
santé et de solidarité qui reste inégalé
mais la la nupes a fait le choix
politicien de déposer sa motion de
censure avant votre déclaration de
politique générale relisez leur motion
il n'y a aucun argument de fond aucun il
déserte le combat des idées peut-être
parce que les quatre partis de l'anupes
n'ont pas la même vision pour la France
alors sur quoi est fondée cette motion
de censure le choix des personnes un
comment com sur leur bilan toujours rien
décrit dans cette motion peut-être parce
que les quatre partis de laanupese ne
partagent pas non plus la même analyse
de notre bilan certains au pouvoir il y
a pas si longtemps auraient rêvé de
notre bilan mais là évidemment nous
venons de l'entendre ils veulent plus
plus vite ils ont évidemment raison
encore une fois mais là encore non'ont
pas honte de pêcher par omission alors
que nous ensemble partie de la majorité
sommes tous fiers de ce bilan et des
ministres qui ont contribué à la
création de 90000 emplois industriel
depuis 2017 qui ont contribué à notre
baisse record des émissions carbon qui
ont été décisifs sur le financement des
études des voies d'accès du lyonturin
dans une négociation entamée il y a
plusieurs mois avec le président de
région qui ont permis à 35000 étudiants
supplémentaires d'accéder à une bourse
et au basculement à l'ch à l'échelon
supérieur de 140000 autres qui ont
initié la constitutionnalisation du
droit à l'IVG qui ont réarmé la France
qui ont préparé notre pays à recevoir le
plus grand événements sportifs et encore
qui ont directement contribué au
Parlement européen au plan de relance à
la taxation des g femes à la taxe
carbone au frontière au pacte européen
sur la migration et bientôt un égalim
Européen en commissaire aux lois je suis
également fière de nos résultats dans la
lutte contre les stupéfiants dans la
lutte contre les passeurs et fi de notre
ministre qui mène ces luttes sans
relâche sans relâche également sa lutte
pour reconnaître l'engagement des
sapports pompiers volontaires et leur
valorisation de la retraite comme dans
la R du clou plafond des loyers de
gendarmerie également fierè du garde des
saau qui défend de toutes ses forces le
service public de la justice à qui nous
avons donné des moyens inédits je
connais bien son combat pour la
réinsertion par le travail en prison et
aussi contre la surpopulation et pour
des conditions de détention dignes c'est
également en confiance que nous
soutenons votre Ministre de
l'Agriculture qui revoit en ce moment
son projet de programmation à l'ône des
manifestations récentes il connaît les
enjeux du modèle agricole qui doit se
réinventer dans tous ces aspects sociaux
fiscaux et gouvernance il est évidemment
conscient de l'urgence particulièrement
pour les petits agriculteurs qu'il
convient désormais de mieux écouter vous
avez d'ailleurs Monsieur le Premier
Ministre assumé avec humilité ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné concernant le GNR qu'il
soit reconduit ou nouvellement arrivé au
sein du gouvernement les membres de
votre équipe sont le reflet d'un large
panel de sensibilité qui nous ont montré
par le percé qu'ils avaient tous la
volonté d'agir pour l'intérêt
général non votre seule lutte commune
pour
finir celle que vous avez décrite dans
votre motion de censure c'est
l'acharnement mesquin sur la ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports qui pourra s'appuyer sur des
fondations solides son propre bilan au
sport
et le vôtre monsieur le Premier ministre
à l'école notre chantier numéro 1 avec
notamment le dédoublement des classes la
revalorisation des salaires la lutte
contre le harcèlement nous savons
qu'elle se battra au côté du corps
enseignant et sportif pour notre
jeunesse alors si ce n'est pas un
problème de fond de personne c'est quoi
il dénonce un problème de méthode comme
le disait le regretter chandlerbing avec
beaucoup
d'autodérision ce n'est pas ce que tu
dis c'est la façon dont tu le dis la
nupess voulait un vote de confiance ils
se sont dit il est jeune sur un
malentendu ça passe il va soumettre son
gouvernement à un vote de confiance mais
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous n'êtes
pas tombé dans le
panneau il crie au
scandale au dénis de démocratie à la
catastrophe comme toujours et à force de
crier au scandale on va devoir renommer
pierre et le loup Jean-Luc et le
loup montés sur leurs grands chevaux ils
vont sur les réseaux sociaux exhumer les
archives jamais vu ça depuis 1993 ils
enrent le tout d'odeur de scandale et
écrit au dénis de démocratie dans les
commentaires un courageux écrira qu'en
majorité relative rocarossussi n'avait
pas soumis son gouvernement au vote de
confiance alors les trolls de la nuupes
corrigeront le faccieux qui le contredit
parce que c'est eux souvenez-vous qui
ont toujours raison sur la méthode comme
sur le fond le groupe Renaissance vous
fait confiance vous avez annoncé vouloir
poursuivre la construction de majorité
de projets comme nous l'avons fait pour
les 63 textes votés 1493 dans le respect
loin des caricatures depuis sa
nomination votre gouvernement a prouvé
sa mobilisation en continuant d'échanger
avec les forces politiques avec les
organisations syndicales avec les élus
locaux notamment dans le Pas de Calais à
la suite des inondations et plus
récemment avec récemment avec nos
agriculteurs vous avez démontré qu'il
n'y a rien d'impossible à qui veut que
des modèles déficitaires enlisés depuis
plusieurs décennies ne vous font pas
peur que les mots justes simple efficace
sont votre vocabulaire que l'écoute
l'humilité sont vos atouts avant une
mise en action puissante dans laquelle
vous entraînez administration et
politique je sens que vous êtes jaloux
pourtant j'avevez dit que vous aviez
toujours raison en démarrage notre
majorité vous accorde donc toute sa
confiance pour aller chercher le dernier
kilomètre ce bout de chemin qu'il reste
à parcourir après avoir fait les
réformes profondes il est parfois plus
dur parce qu'il exige une attention au
moindre détails aux effets de bord au
décret d'application à tous les Français
partout monsieur Premier ministre c'est
votre première motion de censure ce ne
sera pas la
dernière parce que nous la rejetterons
et parce qu'ils en poseront d'autres ils
ont crié au scandale à chaque 493 de
votre prédécesseur madame ellisabeth
borne dont je salue l'action et le
courage mais ne sont pas choqués de
poser d'émotions à chaque occasion à
peine gênés sur le projet de loi
immigration de décembre de l'appel du
pied honteux mais appuyé fait à leurs
alliés de circonstances la droite et son
extrême pour s'étonner ensuite que le
Sénat ait eu trop d'influence sur le
texte final plus d'une cinquantaine de
motions de censure contre le
gouvernement et de rejet préalable à
l'examen de texte des centaines de
personnes mobilisées chacune des
centaines d'heures est-ce que c'est ce
qu'attendent les Français je ne crois
pas ils attendent et reconnaissent en
vous le courage et la responsabilité
nécessaire pour affronter les défis qui
se dressent ils n'attendent d'ailleurs
pas qu'on ait toujours raison du moment
qu'on est en sincérité toujours essayé
de résoudre leurs problèmes
ils veulent simplement qu'on soit à leur
côté à leur écoute pour trouver des
solutions en fait les Français attendent
des actions pas d'émotions qui n'ont
aucun effet sur leur vie j'ai donc
l'honneur chers collègues au nom du
groupe renaissance de vous demander de
rejeter cette motion de censure qui en
vérité n'est qu'une nouvelle motion de
posture je vous remerci ma chè
collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
tangy pour le rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
les victoires idéologiques du
rassemblement national se suivent et se
ressemblent
face à la mobilisation courageuse des
agriculteurs vous avez dû renier vos
programmes d'écologie punitive votre
obsession sadique pour les normes
abusive et votre soutien aveugle au
libre échange vous abandonnez en parole
les marqueurs du macronisme arrogant qui
ruine la France depuis 2017 mais les
Français verront vite que vous restez la
cour roi de transmission cile de la
Commission européenne monsieur hatal
avec vous à Matignon nos victoires
idéologiques s'accélèent ce ne sont plus
seulement nos constats et nos
diagnostics qui s'imposent à vous mais
désormais nos valeurs et nos solutions
le précédent plus jeune premier ministre
de la France Laurent Fabius avait dit à
haute voie que le rassemblement national
posait les bonnes questions vous voilà
Monsieur hatal nouveau Benjamin de
Matignon à reconnaître que les réponses
du rassemblement national sont tout
aussi excellentes hélas nous le verrons
Monsieur le Premier Ministre tous vos
actes contredisent et contrediront vos
paroles pour fuir vos responsabilités et
vos échecs après 7 années au pouvoir
vous pensez pouvoir éviter de de
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale en
dissolvant le macronisme qui eu cru
monsieur hatal que vous aviez l'âme
d'unakamikaz ces soldats d'une cast
niéis qui qui était envoyé à la mort
alors qu'elle se savait déjà perdu
pourtant cette ultime tactique du
système pour conserver le pouvoir se
fracassera vite sur les incohérences
d'Emmanuel Macron faisant hélass perdre
un temps précieux à la France et
aggravant les difficultés des Français
les reniment idéologique qu'a acté votre
catalogue de politique générale
constitue autant de débacles
idéologiques pour la macronie de défaite
en race campagne européenne pour les
bureaucrates de Bruxelles et
d'humiliation pour tous les lâches qui
se sont repus de la haine de la France
depuis trop d'années néanmoins votre
aveu de défaite est une espérance de
victoire pour les Français avec Marine
Le Pen en effet les victoire idéologique
précède toujours les victoires
politiques vous nous avez d'abord donné
raison monsieur le Premier ministre sur
la réindustrialisation que vous êtes
incapable de mener puis sur le nucléaire
dont vous proclamez le champion après
avoir défendu avec la même vigueur la
fermeture de Fessenheim et le sabotage
de toute la filière comme ministre des
comptes publics vous avez repris nos
mots sur le page des classes moyennes
avant de les frapper du plus fort taux
de prélèvement obligatoire de la 5e
République vous n'avez pas non plus eu
de mots assez forts pour nous rejoindre
sur la dérive des comptes publics
pourtant le seul budget que vous avez
porté et construit a créé le plus fort
déficit budgétaire hors covid sans 70
milliards d'euros tout en accumulant la
dette de Monsieur Macron à 900 milliards
d'euros en 7 au pouvoir vous avez
accumulé autant de dettes que tous les
présidents de la République entre 1958
et 2001 comme ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur hatal vous vous êtes
surpassé vous nous avez offert un
triomphe intellectuel sur l'école le
besoin d'autorité et les vertus des
valeurs républicaines au premier rang
desquelles la laïcité et le combat
contre l'islamisme certes toutes vos
postures ne servait qu'à vous attirer
les bonnes grâces de l'opinion publique
mais l'humiliation idéologique que la
macronie s'est infligé àel elle-même est
savoureuse vous voilà monsieur le
ministre à expérimenter en 2024
l'uniforme à l'école dans plusieurs
territoires français vous qui le 12
janvier 2023 rejetiz main dans la main
avec la nupes la même proposition de loi
du rassemblement national dans votre
discours Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous n'avez vous avez confirmé nê qu'à
votre poste que pour combattre le
rassemblement national seule force
politique que vous avez nommément ciblé
vous aurez donc le sombre destin de tous
ceux qui cherchent à prendre les
français pour des imbéciles
présenté comme l'arme redoutable
téléguidée par Emmanuel Macron contre
Marine Le Pen le missile d'armanin s'est
craché sur l'Élysée en portant dans son
souffle le pseudo barrage républicain et
toute sa Corte de socialiste défroqués
rassemblé autour d'Élisabeth borne
acculé à avouer un matin auprès de ses
confesseurs de France interre que oui la
préférence nationale existait déjà pour
le RSA
50 ans de mensonge évanoui en quelques
jours non seulement Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la priorité nationale n'a
jamais rien eu d'infamment mais elle
constitue tout simplement le socle de
toute République sociale viable juste et
humaniste il suffisait d'écouter à ce
titre Jean-Jacques Rousseau comment les
peuples aimeraient-il la patrie si elle
n'est rien de plus pour eux que pour les
étrangers non content d'avoir démontré
que le programme du rassemblement
national était le seul pas pouvoir
réguler l'immigration et que le barrage
républicain n'était qu'une escroquerie
vous avez aussi donné raison à Marine Le
Pen sur la nécessité de réaffirmer la
souveraineté populaire pour que les
paroles politiques soient enfin suivies
d'e faits en dénaturant grave l'État de
droit pour faire jouer au Conseil
constitutionnel un rôle politique
contraire à l'esprit et à la lettre de
notre République Emmanuel Macron a
justifié qu'il faille consulter nos
compatriotes par référendum pour que la
la volonté populaire s'impose au
gouvernement des juges et au
bureaucrates européens un adage simple
que nous appliquerons la séparation des
pouvoirs de Montesquieu qui fait du juge
la bouche de la loi loi don le golisme
de la 5e République établi que son
meilleur juge sinon le seul suprême et
le peuple finalement monsieur le Premier
ministre votre discours monte qu'après
cette année d'échec le macronisme est
devenu l'hommage de vos vices à nos
vertus votre vice c'est de casser notre
vertu ce sera de réparer vous cassez
nous réparons car vous êtes incapable
d'appliquer au macronisme ce que vous
exigez de notre jeunesse vous avez cassé
notre hôpital public nous le réparerons
vous avez cassé l'école du Mérite nous
la réparerons vous avez cassé notre
filière nucléaire nous la réparerons
vous avez cassé l'assimilation
républicaine nous la réparerons vous
vous avez cassé nos frontières nous les
réparerons vous avez cassé la politique
nationaliste du nataliste pardon du CNR
nous la réparerons vous avez cassé la
justice ficiale nous la réparerons vous
avez cassé la politique du logement nous
la réparerons vous avez cassé notre
agriculture nous la réparerons vous avez
cassé notre identité nous la réparerons
vous avez cassé notre ruralité nous la
réparerons vous avez cassé les liens
entre les outr-mères et l'Hexagone nous
les réparerons vous avez cassé le le
rêve d'une Europe des peuples nous la
réparerons bref vous avez cassé la
France Marine Le Pen la réparera avec
tous les
Français car notre vertu car notre vertu
chers collègues c'est le patriotisme
votre vice c'est le brois visiblement
mais c'est surtout le mensonge dans
votre discours vous avez raillé monsieur
le Premier ministre que nous soyons des
cassandres mais monsieur hatal
ignorez-vous que Cassandre avait raison
et qu'elle seule aurait pu sauver sa
patrie de la destruction si on l'avait
écouté nous sommes fiers d'être des
cassandres car nous savons que le
macronisme est le cheval de troit de
tous les mots qui ont affaibli et
affaibliront la France le mondialisme le
communautarisme le niilisme forgé pour
tromper les Français le macronisme n'a
été et restera une tentative désespérée
du système d'unir le pire de la droite
et le pire de la gauche pour se
maintenir au pouvoir ce faisant vous
êtes sans le savoir le talon d'achile
d'une oligarchie qui n'aura bientôt plus
d'emprise sur la France quand je
contemple la débacle politique de la
macronie et le mal que vous avez fait à
la France je ne peux que penser aux mots
de Philippe segin lors de son dernier
grand discours de campagne politique la
bonne conscience de gauche allait se
leverver dans l'argent et la gauche et
la bonne conscience de la gauche allait
tellement aimer cet argent quelle
préciance alors que les idéaux de la
gauche promettaient d'aller à l'assaut
du mur de l'argent elle en est devenue
le ciment idéologique trouvant dans
quelques idiots utiles de la droite des
supplétifs dans sa tâche Philippe segin
avait annoncé que la gauche du fric et
la droite alimentaire ce sont ces mots
allaient s'allier dans un monstrueux
accouplement il ne savait pas que cette
coalition serait le macronisme toute
votre politique consiste à piller les
classes moyennes et populaires les
entrepreneurs et les agriculteurs les
travailleurs et les retraités au seul
bénéfice d'une caste de privilégiés qui
amène toute l'économie occidentale dans
le mur en particulier en France et en
Europe la crise de l'agriculture le
démontre encore de manière tragique
alors que nos compatriotes ont
massivement soutenu la mobilisation de
Françaises et de Français qui voulaient
enfin vivre de leur travail de leur
terre de leurs compétences de la noble
mission de nourrir notre peuple de faire
vivre notre gastronomie et de perpétuer
nos traditions vous n'avez répondu que
par une ynième politique du chèque
aucune remise en cause évidemment du
pouvoir exorbitant de la grande
distribution de leur centrale d'archa et
du condominium qu'elle forment avec les
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire
alors que la France traverse la pire
crise d'inflation alimentaire que notre
peuple est vécu depuis 50 ans rarement
les agriculteurs n'ont aussi mal vécu de
leur travail ce paradoxe intolérable
montre bien que le sacrifice du pouvoir
d'achat des familles ne permet en rien
d'améliorer le revenu des paysans
entre-temps par contre les marges de
l'agro-industrie ont bondit à 40 50 % un
niveau indigne contre lequel votre
gouvernement ne fait rien sinon mendier
des gestes qui n'arrivent que dans votre
imagination ainsi l'ironie a voulu que
les fameuses négociations commerciales
pour faire baisser les prixs
alimentaires entre la grande
distribution à l'industrie se sont
achevés en même temps que la crise
agricole résultat les prixs continueront
d'augmenter de 2 à 3 % à cause des
multinationales pendant que les TPE PME
feront encore et toujours des efforts la
hausse exorbitante des biens des prix
des prix des biens de première nécessité
sera donc définitive et vous n'avez fait
que balader les Français depuis 2 ans
sur des baisses que vous saviez jamais
ne pouvoir obtenir vous avez couvert la
gloutonnerie des multinationales
profiteurs des crises qui estiment
qu'ils doivent toujours pour gagner plus
d'argent et que le ttimulte de nos
sociétés ne les concerne que pour
trouver des prétextes à spéculer et à
s'en mettre plein les poches vous
refuser le rôle d'arbitre que l'État
doit avoir pour éliminer les abus les
ententes et rétablir les relations
loyales mais aussi une économie saine
vous vous prétendez libéraux mais vous
n'êtes que dans la connivance et la
défense des positions dominantes votre
mépris systématique contre la France du
travail et de l'entrepreneuriat est bien
visible dans votre politique fiscale qui
vise depuis 7 ans je l'ai dit à tondre
les Françaises et les Français enracinés
au profit des nomades des oligarques qui
disposent comme bon leur semble de leur
cor de leurs capitaux par-delà les
frontières quand vous étiez ministre des
comptes publics vous avez annoncé
monsieur hatal que vous souhaitiez un
plan Marshal pour les classes moyennes
reconnaissant de facto qu'elles étaient
en ruine après 5 ans de guerre mené par
Emmanuel Macron contre la France du
travail à ce titre monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez ressorti cette belle
promesse de baisser de 2 milliards
d'euros les impôts de la classe moyenne
pour la salingglin tout tout en
augmentant immédiatement de 4 milliards
d'euros la taxe sur la facture
d'électricité avant d'augmenter le 1er
juillet de 10 % la taxe sur le gaz ce
mépris pour la France du travail est la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes si
intimement lié à l'idéologie mondialiste
et au traité de libre échange que vous
signnez au mépris de l'intérêt des
Français mais aussi au mépris même de
l'écologie que vous ne défendez que
lorsqu'elle vous le donne à prétexte
pour taxer nos compatriotes et leur
imposer je ne sais quelle norme N vons
exempter nos concurrents à ce titre
monsieur monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez supprimé 10 normes dans
l'agriculture félicitations sachez qu'il
vous en reste
399999 vos déclarations sur les traités
de libre échange en général et sur le
Mercosur en particulier relèvent tout
simplement de l'escroquerie politique
vous mentez et honteusement aux français
quand vous prétendez vous opposer au
mondialisme ou défendre une exception
agriculturelle si nos paysans n'avaient
pas manifesté vous auriez continué à
laisser filer les négociations avec le
Mercosur comme vous avez laissé aboutir
dès que les médias avaient le dos tourné
les traités avec la Nouvelle-Zélande le
Chili ou le Kenya à ce titre Monsieur le
Premier Ministre où en est le vote du
CTA par notre Parlement voici bientôt 7
ans cette année que le Sénat français
est privé de vote et que cet accord
s'applique au mépris de la souveraineté
française cette situation ubuesque
montre bien que votre votre propagande
sur une souveraineté européenne n'est
rien d'autre qu'un mensonge d'État une
nation est souveraine ou ne l'est pas
elle ne peut pas être souveraine à moi
comme le noté à nouveau Philippe segin
si la Commission européenne est
souveraine pour négocier les accords
commerciaux alors la France ne peut plus
s'y opposer et si la France a le droit
souverain de s'y opposer alors la
Commission européenne ne serait plus
souveraine Monsieur le Premier Ministre
la dernière fois que je vous aveais
interpellé depuis cette tribune je vous
avais comparé à Bonaparte quampis le
qualifié de tragédien et de comédien
vous pardonnerez mon manque de modestie
en constatant que j'avais démasqué ici
votre talent pour incarner tout et son
contraire
votre carrière est comme celle
d'Emmanuel Macron une véritable pyramide
de Ponzi une manipulation qui consiste à
convaincre un maximum de gens de vous
accorder leur confiance avant que d'cun
réalise que vous ne savez absolument pas
où vous les Menz nous vous ferons pas
aujourd'hui le plaisir de vous censurer
et de pouvoir simuler d'affronter des
oppositions stériles la nupes jouera
parfaitement ce rôle d'opposition
fantoche elle qui part de fois à
cocufier ses électeurs en vous offrant
le pouvoir arrivera bien assez vite le
moment vos actes trahiront votre vraie
nature d'Avatar d'Emmanuel Macron ce
jour-l ni vos comédies ni vos tragédies
ne vous sauverons alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ce jourlà nous vous
censurerons car monsieur le Premier
ministre n'est pas Bonaparte qui veut et
comme le disait le Concil lui-même du
sublime au ridicule il n'y a qu'à pas
quand Jupiter vous retirera ses faveurs
la gauche tarpenne sera si proche du
capital je merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
du ponteignan pour une durée de 5
minutes
allez madame la
Présidente vous plat Premier ministre
chers collèg vous n'avez pas osé
accompagner votre déclaration de
politique générale d'un vot
comme il est de tradition car vous savez
que vous êtes minoritaire dans cette
assemblée comme dans le pays aussi pour
mettre chaque député devant ses
responsabilités cette motion de censure
est la bienvenue je la voterai bien sûr
pour trois raisons fondamentales
première raison vous donner aujourd'hui
un surcis ferait de nous députés de la
nation les complices de la pure
opération de communication qu' a
constitué votre nomination à matigon qui
peut croire un instant que vous allez
changer de politique il suffisait
d'écouter votre avec attention votre
déclaration de mardi dernier un
catalogue de mesurettes avec tellement
de priorités qu'il n'y en a plus aucune
pour comprendre combien vous étiez la
voix de votre maître Emmanuel Macron ne
pas voter la censure reviendrait
concrètement à faire souffrir d'avantage
les Français et à faire perdre encore
plus de temps à la France doublement des
franchises médicales l'explosion des
tarifs de l'électricité et du gaz
appauvrissement sans précédent des
chômeurs de longue durée tout en
régularisant une manœuvre bon marché
hausse des tarifs des autoroutes
réduction de 3 ans à 6 mois du congé
parental et vous osez affirmer que vous
voulez défendre les classes moyennes de
même vous n'avez que le mot autorité à
la bouche mais vous ne voulez pas vous
attaquer aux causes profondes de
l'explosion de la délinquence le laxisme
judiciaire l'ouverture des frontières la
soumission à un droit européen qui
explique l'impuissance généralisée de
l'État mais plus grave encore ne pas
voter la censure reviendrait à
cautionner le vrai cap d'Emmanuel Macron
et de votre gouvernement la dissolution
de la France dans une Union européenne
de plus en plus inefficace et
autoritaire contrairement à ce que vous
avez voulu nous faire croire dans votre
discours de mardi dernier pour endormir
les fr fr vis-à-vis du saut fédéral que
vous êtes en train de préparer il n'est
pas possible de courir deux lièvres à la
fois celui de la souveraineté française
et celui de la souveraineté européenne
par exemple votre promesse à Paris de
bloquer l'accord de libre échange Union
européenne Mercosur et les déclarations
de la Commission européenne qui annonc
le signer au plus vite révèle votre
double jeu Total derrière les grandes
envolé lyriques il s'agit d'un véritable
holdup intellectuel pour pour cacher un
transfert historique de compétences de
pouvoir à l'échelon supranational comme
en témoigne la révision des traité en
préparation Philippe seggin avait
d'ailleurs tout résumé par ses mots par
essence je le cite la souveraineté est
un absolu qui exclut toute idée de
subordination et de compromission un
peuple souverain n'a de compte à
résoudre à personne compte à rendre à
personne enfin je voterai la motion de
censure car je ne peux pas cautionner
ici même les AMS d'Emmanuel Macron et de
votre gouvernement en matière de
politique étrangère et de
défense la déclaration hallucinante du
président de la République à Stockholm
mes chers collègues
bradant dans la confusion la plus totale
en langue anglaise de sur croix notre
force de dissuasion nucléaire nationale
à nos voisins européens
rond avec des décennies de cohérence et
de clarté de ses
prédécesseurs notre dissuasion nucléaire
n'a de sens et n'est d'ailleurs
dimensionné que pour sanctuiriser le
territoire national et empêcher le
franchissement de ses frontières
l'tendre avec inconscience à un théâtre
européen menacé par l'extension de la
guerre en Ukraine revient à transformer
notre force nucléaire stratégique en un
outil tactique pouvant déclencher une
escalade nucléaire et sacrifier les
français pour une guerre qu'il n'auraiit
pas voulu il était à cet égard c'est
totalement juste relisez ce qu'a écrit
le président de la République et a dit
le président de la République il est à
cet égard inconcevable que notre
Parlement ne se soit pas réuni en
application de l'article 35 de la
constitution contte tenu de la fuite en
avant des livraisons d'armes toujours
plus importantes d'Emmanuel Macron par
son obéissance servile à l'Union
européenne et et à
l'OTAN sur la scène internationale la
France n'est plus que l'ombre
d'elle-même elle n'incarne plus la voix
libre capable de défendre un plan de
paix équilibré l'heure est grave les
Français nous regardent pour ma part je
ne cautionnerai jamais la dérive
actuelle seule une censure suivie d'une
dissolution permettant l'arbitrage du
peuple peut enrayer l'effondrement du
pays tout le reste n'est que bavardage
dilatoire je vous remci je vais mettre
maintenant en voie la motion de censure
le scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale je rappelle que
seuls les députés favorables à la motion
de censure participent au scrutin et que
le vote se déroule dans les salles
voisines de l'hémicycle le scrutin est
ouvert pour une durée de 20 minutes il
sera donc clos à euh
12h08 merci merci beaucoup peu
seul c'est in
ouais comment va vont naître les rumeurs
la séance est
reprise donc voici le résultat du
scrutin majorité requise pour l'adoption
de la motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composants
l'assemblée 289 pour l'adoption 124 la
majorité requise nétant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée et
la séance est levée prochaine séance
demain à 15h merci à tous merci monsieur
le Premier
ministre